[Musique]
Pascal Boniface, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Bien sûr,
Pascal Bonifa, je dirige et fondé l'IRIS
qui est l'Institut de relations
nationales et stratégiques. J'étais
aussi universitaire à la FAC et donc
j'ai commencé par des études de droit et
je me suis ensuite spécialisé sur la
géopolitique.
Première question,
comment vous analysez le bavardage
médiatique, l'échec médiatique de
l'anticipation 1 de la campagne
américaine, 2 de la guerre avec les
Russes ? 3 de tout un tas de sujets
comme la crise financière et je vous en
passe des meilleurs. Comment vous
analysez ça ? Que nos géopolitologues,
nos géostratèges, nos gens de
renseignement soient au meilleur des cas
borgnes et dans le pire des cas
complètement aveugles ?
Alors, je dirais pas ça de tout le monde
et même pour
sans faire de généralité, je suis
d'accord avec vous. Moi-même, je n'ai
pas anticipé la guerre en Ukraine. Je ne
pensais pas que lorsque Poutine
envoie 160000 soldats à la frontière, on
contrôle pas un pays de 40 millions
d'habitants avec seulement 160000
soldats. Pour mémoire, en
Tchécoslovaquie, en 68, 11 millions
d'habitants, 400000 soldats. Donc je me
suis gouré mais je crois que sur le fait
que Poutine allait lancer la guerre,
tous les spécialistes de la Russie se
sont gourés en réalité parce que lui
s'est trompé, c'est que c'était pas dans
ses je d'habitude défendait
rationnellement les intérêts russes.
Ça c'est la supputation de
géopolitologue.
Oui, peut-être. Mais en tous les cas
non, le fait est que il a quand même
diminué le statut de la Russie sur la
scène internationale notamment par
rapport à la Chine avec cette guerre.
Donc
je peux vous couper
parce qu'on va rentrer dans le vi du
sujet puis comme vous êtes déjà venu on
va pas vous prendre avec des pincettes.
OK.
Si je vous présente la chose suivante,
les exercices pour sortir de Swift, les
exercices pour sortir d'Internet, la
rénovation des hôpitaux en bruot de
Moscou, ce genre de petit détail, vous
les avez pas vu venir parce que vous
êtes pas sur le terrain, vous avez pas
les bonnes sondes. Comment ça se fait ?
Oui, effectivement la rénovation des
hôpitaux, non, il y avait pas justement
de construction d'hôpitaux de campagne
autour. Donc ça semblait ne pas amener
la guerre. Mais une fois encore, je
crois que tous ceux qui avaient étudié
l'attitude de Poutine, il a une rupture
là. Il a une rupture et effectivement on
aurait pu voir son article avant. Enfin,
en tous les cas, ce que je veux dire par
là, c'est que il y a se tromper et il a
mentir qui est deux choses différentes.
C'est différent de dire il faut
intervenir en Irak parce qu'il y a des
armes nucléaires alors qu'on sait qu'il
y en a pas. Je se tromper, bah vous
trompez, tout le monde peut se tromper.
Il faut juste reconnaître ces erreurs
avec humilité et essayer de recommencer.
Je me suis trompé sur le fait que
Poutine ait lancé une guerre contre
l'Ukraine. Il y a d'autres choses sur
lequelles je me suis pas trompé, mais je
crois qu'il y a vraiment la différence
fondamentale d'induire en erreur
volontairement les gens pour des
intérêts très particuliers, par
militantes, par intérêt personnel et
cetera et le fait
par ingérence étrangère.
Oui, l'intérêt personnel peut être aussi
d'être au service d'une puissance
étrangère. Euh, il faut pas mettre de
côté le côté moutonnier. C'est-à-dire
que en fait dans les médias, une fois
encore, je veux il faut distinguer et
vous le faites et cetera, mais il y a un
côté un peu ce que j'ai vu notamment
avec la guerre en Ukraine et encore plus
avec la guerre de Gaza. Euh c'est vous
connaissez le système de l'assiette au
beurre, vous êtes en haut et si vous
glissez un peu, vous êtes éjecté. Et en
fait, j'ai vu plein de gens notamment
sur la guerre Russie-Ukraine et encore
pure sur la guerre de Gaza qui ne
voulaient pas se séparer de l'opinion
majoritaire parce que ils avaient peur
que s'ils se séparent de l'opinion
majoritaire, on va dire qu'ils sont pro
Poutine et on va ne plus inviter parce
qu'on n'invite pas quelqu'un qui est pro
Poutine. Et donc en fait ce qu'on a vu
avec la guerre en Ukraine c'est des
gens, je connais des gens qui ont
complètement changé en disant il faut
être du côté du vainqueur et cetera et
on a surtout perdu la nuance et que on
était si par exemple moi j'ai dit p je
dis toujours cette guerre aurait pu être
évitée on a multiplié les erreurs à
l'égard de la Russie la guerre du Kosovo
pour commencer l'élargissement de l'OTAN
le déploiement d'un système de défense
antimissile l'intervention en Libye
alors qu'il y avait une absorption russe
qui a beaucoup contribué au rissement.
Tout ça bien sûr, on nen parle pas si
vous dites ça. Bon et et donc on a fait
beaucoup d'erreurs à la guerre de la
Russie. Aucune d'entre elles n'excuse la
guerre mais en fait c'est l'un ou
l'autre. Donc soit vous condamnez la
guerre mais faut pas dire qu'il y a eu
des erreurs. Sinon c'est toujours le
même truc expliquer c'est légitimé.
C'est cette phrase qui est un peu guerre
à l'intelligence en fait mort à
l'intelligence. Et donc non expliquer
n'est pas légitimé. Et donc si on veut
comprendre les choses, si on veut par
exemple ne pas faire à la gare de la
Chine les mêmes erreurs que celles qu'on
a fait à la guerre de la Russie parce
qu'on les payerait encore plus cher, bah
il faut expliquer et expliquer n'est pas
légitimer. Et donc, j'ai déjà vu ça moi
sur la guerre Russie-Ukraine où en fait
bah les plateaux vous aviez une
ukrainienne qui était forcément éple
pleurer, on peut l'être quand on voit
les crimes de guerre qui sont faits, des
gens qui avaient vécu à l'OTAN donc qui
étaient quand même un petit peu disons
bon qui étaient orienté et puis bah des
gens qui se disaient "Ah si je ne fais
pas de la alors des gens qui étaient
vraiment convaincus de faire la
surenchère contre Poutine parce que
Poutine était quand même disons
diabolisé depuis qu'il arriva au
pouvoir, il n'a jamais été populaire en
France, il n'a jamais été populaire dans
le monde occidental. Donc il il y a
toujours eu les les médias étaient quand
même très antipoutine. Alors les gens
vous disent maintenant ah on vous
l'avait bien dit bah ça se discute.
Qui dit ça ? Bah tous ceux qui euh
disons le le clan des néoconservateurs
euh le clan de ceux qui disaient il
fallait pas négocier avec Poutine, on
peut aussi dire c'est que ce sont ces
gens-là qui ont toujours dit qu'il
fallait pas traiter avec Poutine, qu'il
fallait pas faire un sommet Union
européenne Russie alors qu'il devait
d'avoir un sommet euh États-Unis Russie.
C'est tous les gens qui ont dit non il
faut pas traiter avec la Russie qui ont
fait que Poutine s'est dit bah j'ai rien
à gagner, j'ai plus rien à attendre de
l'Europe occidentale. Les seuls patrons,
ce sont les États-Unis. ces pays
d'Europe en fait ne font qu'obéir aux
États-Unis. Et donc il y a deux façons
de voir les choses. Certains vous disent
"Ah, on vous l' euh on vous l'avait bien
dit, on ne peut pas négocier avec
Poutine." Et d'autres peuvent dire "Bah,
écoutez, si on avait été un peu plus
précautionneux dans la façon de traiter
la Russie et qu'on l'avait pas traité
comme un pays qui avait
qui avait été vaincu dans la guerre
froide, et bien tel que ça ait changé."
J'ai longtemps fréquenté les cercles qui
étaient organisés autour de Gorbadchev
qui faisait un sommet par an. Ça diminua
au fur et à mesure. J'ai toujours
entendu Gorbal Chevf critiquer
l'attitude des occidentaux par rapport à
la Russie. Il critiquait Poutine en
politique intérieure mais il était assez
pour sa politique je pense qu'il aurait
pas approuvé la guerre en Ukraine mais
le fait de résister au monde occidental
le fait de dire que les occidentaux j'ai
entendu plusieurs fois Gorbatchev dire
qu'il avait été trahi par les
occidentaux et que les Américains
avaient préféré apparaître comme les
vainqueurs de la guerre froide que comme
les bâtisseurs d'un ordre mondial
nouveau que par ailleurs il célébrait.
Et donc vous savez, il y a deux dates
quand même importantes. Les Nations-
Unies ont dit que ça marche pas. En 90
pour moi c'est intonnant de la guerre
froide. En 90 Gorbatchef accepte de ne
pas protéger son allié iraakien qui
vient d'envillir le cohète et de dire
bah voilà non priorité au droit
international
et c'est plus les les véaux pour
protéger les copains ou soi-même. C'est
un tournant. C'est la première fois que
l'ONU a utilisé la comme c'était prévu
dans la charte. Donc regardez la
différence entre la guerre du golf de 90
et la guerre diagre de 2003. C'est une
guerre contre un violateur du droit
international soutenu par la communauté
internationale qui était ensemble ce
coup-ci. Et en fait après on a ça c'est
le plus en fait l'un des plus grands
apports de Gorbatchef dans la fin de la
guerre froide. Plus encore enfin autant
que de libérer l'Europe de l'Est et
cetera. Il dit on va le droit va
prévaloir sur la force et donc il s'est
pas absolu. Il a voté pour la résolution
678 qui prévoit une action militaire
contre l'Irak si l'Irak n'a pas quitté
le Ket au 15 janvier 91. Et après en
juillet, il vient au sommet du G7, il
demande une aide parce que il est c'est
le bordel économique et John Major dit
bah non et des lures c'est arroser le
désert. Et deuxième exemple euh aussi,
c'est 2011 l'intervention en Libye. On
n' pas suffisamment encore euh comment
réfléchi aux conséquences parce que
rappelez-vous à l'époque c'est le
triomphe de la morale, une guerre pour
le bien et cetera. Bon voilà, on n pas
hésité. Alors Kfi était répulsif certes,
mais toujours est-il que Medvedev est
président à l'époque. Medvedev
s'abstient sur la résolution 1973 qui
prévoit d'aller protéger la population
de Bazi avec la Chine qui s'abstient et
aussi l'Allemagne qui s'abstient et
l'Afrique du Sud. Cinq pays
s'abstiennent. Donc on fait
l'intervention, elle est légale et après
qu'est-ce que l'on fait ? Ben, on change
la mission en cours de route et on nous
dit "Ah mais tant que Kaddafi sera au
pouvoir, la population libenne ne sera
pas en sécurité. Donc il faut faire du
changement de régime." Et là, c'est une
rupture totale pour la Russie parce que
Poutine avait dit "Ah vedev, tu vas
voir, ils vont avoir les occidentaux."
C'est pas mais dis "Non, vous tu sais,
je me rapproche d'eux." que c'était à
l'époque on disait que Nedev pouvait
devenir président, qu'en 2012 il avait
ses chances contre Poutine. Et là bien
sûr c'était une faillite totale. Il a
passé pour un incompétent, pour un
faible, pour quelqu'un qui s'est fait
berner par et donc ça a été la fin pour
lui. Et Poutine est revenu au pouvoir et
la grande phrase de Poutine, c'est pas
seulement que la disparition de l'URS a
été la plus grande faillite géopolitique
du 20e siècle, c'est que la grande
erreur des Russes après la fin de la
guerre froide, c'est d'avoir fait
confiance dans les occidentaux. Et la
grande erreur des occidentaux, c'est
leur a pris cette confiance pour de la
faiblesse. Et ensuite, le comportement
russe a changé. Lavrov a dit à Fabius :
"Vous nous avez baisé sur la Libye, vous
nous baiserez pas sur la Syrie."
C'est quoi vos sources ?
Le cheval. La bouche du cheval.
La bouche du cheval. Revenons. Revenons
à l'anticipation médiatique et nos
astrologues de plateau télé.
Vous avez écouté un peu ce que a raconté
Joassange concernant le fait que les
institutions politiques médiatiques de
STAN étaient vérôé de l'intérieur par la
CIA.
Alors vérolé de l'intérieur peut-être
que le mot est excessif.
Je ne vois pas chez moi quelqu'un qui
serait véoré pas la CIA et je ne dirai
pas que mes collègues le sont tous mais
il y a une stratégie d'influence. On a
beaucoup parlé même que celle que la
Chine ou du Qatar, du Maroc, de la
Russie.
Ah elle est beaucoup plus efficace.
parce que moins visible, on en parle
pas. Moi je dire quand quand vous êtes
en contact avec les services qui
regardent un peu quelles ont été les
approches,
vous êtes en contact avec des services.
Alors des fois on nous demande un peu
voilà est-ce qu'on a eu des approches de
puissance étrangère ? Oui oui oui oui.
Et je leur dis mais vous vous regardez
jamais les pays d'y alliés parce que
leur influence peut être grande. Ah oui
non c'est compliqué donc euh c'est plus
délicat. Donc en fait les États-Unis ils
ont pas besoin enfin ils ont une
tragédiein influence mais ça passe par
quoi ?
Ça passe bah par Yel, par Harvard, ça
passe par le jama, ça passe par le soft
power attractif où les gens
s'accoutument le nombre de gens qui sont
qui vont dans des coloques de l'OTAN,
l'OTAN la croisée des chemins et cetera.
À force de fréquenter les mêmes
personnes, vous pensez la même chose.
Donc c'est pas Alors, il y a quelques
personnes qui sont effectivement
stipendiers. Il y en a aussi qui sont
stimandiés par les Russes et par les
Chinois. C'est une minorité. C'est c'est
très rare, c'est l'exception. Ce qui est
plus, c'est l'accoutumance psychologique
et la volonté d'appartenir à un groupe
dans lequel on se sent bien,
confortable, c'est démocratique, on est
bien reçu, bah on va pas péter dans le
salon quoi, on va pas dire des choses
qui sont désagréables. Et donc il y a
une sorte d'accoutumance du fait que à
force de voir tout le temps les mêmes
personnes et ben vous appartenez à un
groupe dont vous ne voulez pas vous
séparer parce que ce groupe est
chaleureux et vous parvenez à penser la
même chose. Je vous coupe si vous
m'autorisez.
Je reprends votre expression. Vous êtes
vous
Merci bien.
Le Je reprends votre expression pété
dans le salon. Est-ce que c'est pas un
peu ça qui nous manque en France ?
C'est-à-dire la stérilisation de la
pensée parce qu'on a peur de mettre des
points de vues différents sur la table.
Est-ce que nos médias, nos sy tank, nos
services de renseignement et j'en passe
sont devenus sourds, aveugles, borgnes à
force d'être consensuel ? Alors, les
services de renseignement, je suis pas
sûr. Après, euh et il faut encore, ça
dépend mais effectivement, alors vous
avez soit des faux clash, on prend des
gens parce que vous avez des médias, ils
aiment bien le clash mais en fait les
gens s'engueulent en pensant la même
chose. En fait, ils parlent fort mais
ils disent la même chose. Donc, c'est
pas une vraie confrontation d'idées. Et
d'autres effectivement et bien vous
excluez du mouvement si vous donnez moi
les positions que j'avais sur la Russie.
euh dans de nombreux médias. Du coup,
j'étais plus invité à l'air. J'étais
plus invité dans l' J'ai participé à
cette émission depuis le début depuis la
création en 2001. J'étais un des piliers
de l'émission. Je crois que les
téléspectateurs m'aimaient bien. Il y a
un moment où vraiment on programmait les
émissions si j'étais là et cetera. Bah
après plus de monde est venu, enfin et
cetera. Et là en fait bah non, je ne
participais pas
au consensus occidental.
Et donc et ben on alors après on a on
l'a plus invité al plus qu'en 7 octobre
encore pire puisque j'étais diabolisé
sur les position sur Israël plus
d'invitation et après ils ont voulu
m'inviter sur les jeux olympiques. Je
écoute ça suffit non euh je voilà
j'ai on va pas avec des caramels mou
quand même bon quoi mais donc
effectivement vous avez le fait et moi
je vois des des gens qui ont peur. Vous
savez, il y a Harari explique très bien
dans son dernier bouquin le système de
la chasse aux sorcières au Moyen-Âge.
Vous dites qu'il y a quelqu'un qui vole
sur un balai et qui se nourrit du sang
d'enfant, bah faut qu'elle avoue parce
que c'est quand même très grave. Donc on
la torture pour qu'elle avoue et comme
elle torture, elle va dire qu'il y a des
complices. On va aussi torturer les
complices en voir plein de monde. Puis
il y a quelques personnes qui se disent
"Ouais, peut-être que quand même ça
marche pas comme ça. Peut-être qu'elles
veulent pas vraiment sur un balai et
cetera." Mais le mec qui dit ça, il est
torturé à son tour parce qu'il fait
partie de du complot. Donc en fait, on a
du mal à sortir du troupeau. On a du mal
à sortir du troupeau mais en même temps
quand on en sort marche. Bah le succès
de votre chaîne par exemple. Donc
effectivement on voit bien qu'il y a une
demande quand même du public pour dire
ça serait bien qu'on ne raconte pas que
des salades, ça serait bien qu'on ait un
autre avis parce que bah force vous nous
vous endormez. Euh ce qui ce qui est
vraiment gênant, c'est que cet
unanimisme nourrit le complotisme que
l'on dénonce par ailleurs. Et donc les
gens vont vous dire, oninvite que des
gens qui pensent pareil. En fait, vous
avez quand même beaucoup de journalistes
qui vous invitent, qui invitent
quelqu'un parce qu'il pense comme lui.
Donc il invite son reflet. Il invite son
reflet et cetera. Et après, on va dire
"Ah bah tiens, les médias et cetera."
Donc je crois qu'il faut distinguer.
Non, c'est pas les médias tous pourris.
Il y a des journalistes qui font leur
boulot d'investigation, qui
réfléchissent, qui peuvent se tromper
mais qui souvent ont raison et en tous
les cas qui disent ce qu'ils pense et
qui ne viennent pas dire ce qu'ils
doivent penser pour plaire aux autres.
Et vous et moi je connais enfin j'ai vu
des spécialistes envoyer leur
intervention à un parlementaire ou un
ministre pour dire "Vous voyez, j'ai dit
ça pour recevoir une sorte de câlin et
cetera." Bon euh bon euh donc non,
écoutez, il faut dire les choses, il
faut rester courtois et cetera, mais
effectivement euh vous sortez du
troupeau et donc bon et donc vous avez
des gens qui se disent "Bah c'est
confortable le troupeau, on est bien
traité, on est reçu, on est reconnu dans
la rue, c'est sympa et tout, des fois il
y a des petites primes et tout." Bon,
vendre des bouquins.
Ouais, on peut vendre des bouquins. Les
bouquins, enfin bon et cetera. Enfin,
dans tous les cas, on n pas on fait
société euh et se séparer de ça, c'est
un peu comme finalement un type qui
aurait été communiste dans les années 80
et qui dit "Mais [__] tout ça, ça
déconne." Bah s'il quitte le PC, il
quitte tout son cercle. Il voilà. Et
donc il y a quand même une sorte
bah effectivement de d'effet un peu de
masse qui fait que on a du mal. Alors
ceci est temps, je connais des gens qui
le font. Vous avez des gens qui en
plateau prennent des positions
courageuses. Je dirais pas que c'est pas
comme les poissons volants, mais enfin
c'est quand même pas la majorité de
l'espèce. Euh mais il y a quand même un
caractère puis un autre phénomène, vous
avez besoin de 200 personnes par jour
pour nourrir les plateaux. Les
différents plateaux de toutes les
chaînes d'info.
Je suis pas sûr que tout le monde soit
compétent. Je suis pas sûr que à force
d'avoir 200 personnes, vous avez 200
couteaux bien affutés dans le tiroir
quoi. Bon,
est-ce que les politiques utilisent les
les couteaux à beurre pour les
conseiller sur les questions
internationales ? Quand on voit Bruno
Lem dire "Nous allons mettre l'économie
russe à genou", quand on voit les
répercussions de cette guerre sur notre
industrie et sur nos capacités
éventuelles à pouvoir ressortir le nez
de la flotte avec la la tasse qu'on
vient de prendre, est-ce que vous pensez
que nos géopolitologues professionnels,
patentés
en fait sont pas un peu des tocars
abreuvés avec des bouquins de tocar de
plateau télé et et qu'on se retrouve
maintenant avec
une voie évolutive qui ressemble plus à
une impasse des perspectives sur
l'emploi sur notre croissance sur notre
pays
non vous avez des gens qui ont alerté
hein sur l'erreur des sanctions et
cetera sur vous avez quand même
plusieurs personnes qui ont dit
attention qui qui ont alerté avant le
début de la guerre comme quoi on
antagonisait ils
ils ont alerté nos politiques ou ils ont
alerté sur les plateaux télé
bah aussi dans les contacts que l'on
pouvait avoir. Après, vous savez, je
pense que un militaire m'a expliqué en
m'expliquant les rapports de force que
en fait nos politiques avaient réagi par
rapport à la pression médiatique.
La pression médiatique c'était
l'émotion. Les Ukrainiens souffrent, ils
ont les mêmes bagnoles que nous et
cetera. Donc c'est pas bien qu'il
souffre. Et donc au tout début, ça a été
vraiment une réaction émotionnelle. On n
pas regardé où sont nos intérêts,
qu'est-ce que l'on doit faire et cetera.
Ça a été. Et il y a une catégorie de
disons que les débats permanents
alimentent un peu. Vous allez dans un
bureau d'un ministre, il a plein d'écran
télé partout et cetera. Enfin ça tout le
monde ne regarde pas ça mais il y a
beaucoup d'influence et donc on a cédé à
l'émotion. Mais une fois encore, et vous
le savez vous-même, est-ce que vous
interviewez quand même pas mal de gens
qui me paraissent plutôt lucides et qui
ont plutôt raconter pas des conneries
aussi bien ceux qui ceux qui ont
anticipé leur guerre avec l'Ukraine euh
euh il y a très longtemps, ils veulent
plus faire de sortie médiatique parce
qu'ils sont fait à l'époque vilipendé
chasse aux sorcières. Euh leur santé a
été attaquée tellement ils se faisaient
par États-Unis.
Non, en France. Oui, mais aux États-Unis
euh Stephen Walter raconte très bien
dans dans son livre sur le l'enfer des
bonnes intentions que tous ceux qui se
sont posés à la guerre d'Irak en 2003
aux États-Unis, ils ont pas retrouvé de
boulot après. Et ceux qui avaient dit
"C'est formidable, ça va être un chemin
euh de pétal de rose et où le miel va
couler". Euh et bah ils sont ils sont
passés du département d'État à un
fingtang, ils sont toujours là. c'est
que les gens en fait voilà,
le miel va couler, les dates sont
pleines. Vous connaissez l'expression ?
Voilà. En fait euh vous pouvez le
choisir d'être insider ou outsider. Si
vous êtes insider, vous faites partie du
monde, vous êtes reçu, vous êtes invité,
c'est bien. Il y a une règle numéro 1,
ne jamais critiquer les autres insiders.
Jamais. Et si vous dites "Ah mais machin
la raconte", enfin même si vous dites
poliment euh "Non mais écoutez là, je
suis pas d'accord avec vous ou ce que
vous ce que vous avez dit, c'est une
connerie." le mec va vous en vouloir.
C'est normal si vous lui baissez le
pantalon en public, il va vous en
vouloir. Et donc si vous le contredisez
de façon trop ferme et plus ça sera
justifié, plus il vous en voudra. Donc
en fait les gens se disent "Bon je vais
pas me faire un ennemi." Ce qu'il
raconte c'est des craques, mais je veux
pas me faire un ennemi. Et donc je ne
dis rien. Moi ce qui m'a coûté le plus
en terme d'exclusion du monde
médiatique, c'est pas tellement mon
bouquin est-il permis de critiquer
Israël comme beaucoup de gens le disent.
C'est mon bouquin sur les intér
faosires.
On va on va revenir sur les
intellectuels faosser mais j'aimerais
qu'on revienne sur le côté moutonnier
de on ne critique pas son copain
insider. Imaginez-vous en France,
d'après ce que Julien Assange nous a
fait remonter, que
la CIA est infiltrée dans nos médias,
dans nos politiques et que l'émotion
créée par une guerre fait agir nos
politiques dans un sens à la fois tordu
et dirigé par une puissance étrangère
autre que Moscou, Pierre ou Paul
Jacques. Ça pose quand même des
problèmes. Est-ce que vous avez senti
nos propres services mis à part le fait
qu'il fallait pas critiquer nos alliés,
que c'étaient nos copains et que on se
faisait des gros bisous sur la bouche ?
Est-ce que vous avez pas senti une
petite faiblesse de nos services de
renseignement ? Premier exemple, la DRM,
direction du renseignement militaire qui
disait "Non mais vous inquiétez pas, il
y aura pas de frappe. Les Russes vont
pas envahir parce qu'ils ont pas envoyé
leur hôpitaux de campagne. Il y a pas de
poche de sang derrière les premières
lignes. Est-ce que ça c'est pas
problématique ? On part sur une guerre
qui va coûter des milliers de milliards
à l'Europe, des milliers de vies à
l'Europe, que ce soit côté ukrainien ou
côté russe. et on se retrouve avec des
néoconservateurs américains qui
potentiellement pousseraient nos propres
gouvernements européens à travers la
pression médiatique, l'infiltration de
leurs propres institutions vers quelque
chose qui est contre les intérêts
européens
et avantageux pour les États-Unis à
moyen terme et long terme. Court terme.
Ouais,
vous comprenez ce que j'essaie de dire
ou bien sûr. Alors je dire pour la DRM,
je suis pas en contact avec eux mais je
pense que s'ils ont fait cette erreur
que vous signalez, c'est pas pour faire
plaisir aux Américains
parce que c'est des c'est des manches
des des tanches.
Non mais tout le monde peut se gourrer
une fois. Mais quand on a la DRM, on se
gourt pas.
Bah si, enfin l'erreur, l'histoire est
truffée d'erreur d'analyse et cetera. La
CIA se gour en pensant qu'en envoyant
500 mecs, Castro va tomber et cetera.
Enfin bon, vraiment c'est bon.
Mais des cochons.
Ouais. Donc euh bon, mais en fait euh
moi ce que je constate c'est que dans
mon milieu professionnel, je suis
minoritaire
parce que je pense être majoritaire dans
l'opinion et minoritaire dans mon milieu
professionnel.
J'évolue dans un milieu professionnel
qui est atlantiste, qui est
occidentaliste. Les gens sont grosso
modo convaincus. sincèrement d'autres
une petite minorité par intérêt
personnel, d'autres à force de dire les
choses vous finissez par y croire que le
monde occidental a des valeurs
supérieures aux autres, qu'il est normal
de vouloir les exporter y compris avec
des B52, c'est pour leur bien et cetera
comme les types qui brûlaient les
sorcières dans le temps étaient persuadé
que c'était pour le bien des sorcières
parce que on on les évitait, ils
mouraient là, ils souffraient pas
longtemps, après ils allaient au paradis
sinon ils allaient en enfer donc c'était
quand même pour leur bien. Donc vous
avez plein de gens qui pensent ça qui
pensent qui sont parce que il y a un
bain amiotique occidental où les gens
qui travaillent sur ces sujet là pense
quand même grosso modo la même chose
parce qu'il fréquentent les mêmes
cercles, les cerclesiens et cetera et
que les gens qui pensent un peu en
dehors de la boîte avec une vision plus
décalée qui intègre beaucoup plus le sud
qui intègre une perspective non
occidentale bah sont plutôt
minoritaires. On est en France quand
même la jouatoire c'est dans notre ADN.
Je me rappelle des joratoires que
j'avais avec Pierre Asner, Jacques
Andréani où pour être tout à fait clair,
on se foutait sur la gueule à coup de
chaise.
Oui, mais là Pierre Asner c'était quand
même je veux dire moi ça a été mon prof.
On a eu ensuite quand je suis devenu à
mon tour enseignant et expert, on a eu
des débats. On était pas d'accord sur
l'ingérance. Il avait son histoire moi
la mienne mais c'est un débat de
qualité. pas bien entendu.
C'était et Pierre Asner avait ses
convictions qui venait de son parcours
personnel de réfugiés des pays de l'Est.
Pai à son âme.
Bon et paix à son âme et pas du tout par
bon voilà et donc pour Jacques Andréani
aussi.
Oui. Donc c'est c'était une autre
époque. Je pense aussi que le niveau a
un peu baissé peut-être dans certains
cas dans certains milieux politiques.
Mais donc en fait quand même moi je veux
dire je vois très bien je fais beaucoup
de conférences en région dans le public.
J'ai quand même bout de coup de contact
sur les sociaux. Les gens le qui disons
le le français
qui n'est pas professionnellement dans
la géopolitique, il est golo
mitérandiste. Il pense que c'est mieux
que la France soit indépendante et qu'on
a pas obricains et qu'on est allié mais
pas aligné. Il est pas anti-américain.
Je veux dire moi souvent dit il est
anti-américain mais pas du tout. Je suis
pas anti-américain, j'aime le cinéma
américain, j'ai la société américaine,
j'aime bien aller aux États-Unis mais
j'ai pas envie qu'il me dise ce que mon
pays doit faire. C'est quand même une
nuance importante et j'aime les
États-Unis quand ils font des choses
positives, pas quand ils lancent la
guerre d'Irak et qu'on me dit que si je
suis opposé à la guerre d'Irak, c'est
que je suis pro dictature et pro sadame.
Bon donc c'était
mais ça ça le on le voit avec d'aut
d'autres conflits. Il y a un package de
communication qui va toujours avec sur
la guerre en Irak. Clair. Clair. C'est
c'est clair parce que effectivement ceux
qui sont pour la guerre ont quand même
une bataille médiatique à mener et après
vous avez des gens qui sont convaincus,
des gens qui sont opportunistes, des
gens qui ont la trouille et qui suivent
le mouvement parce que bah c'est des
perroquets, ils répètent ce qu'ils
entendent et c'est plus facile de
répéter ce que disent les autres que
d'avoir une pensée originale. Donc
effectivement, on il y a quand même une
sorte de conformisme. Alors, les gens
qui ne sont pas d'accord avec moi vont
dire que alors bon, je vous passe les
payés par les Chinois, les Russes, le
Qatar, les Émirat, les Turcs et cetera.
C'estquel qui paye le mieux d'ailleurs ?
Bah malheureusement aucun. C'est pas
sinon bon mais c'est c'est Je vous coupe
encore.
Je suis désolé pour la communauté.
Pourquoi on a essayé de vous raccrocher
des casseroles au cul comme ça ? Je je
me rappelle qu' un rapport de l'IRSEM
vous a vous a vilé. Oui, parce que on
avait qu'organisé un colloque avec
l'ambassade de Chine et il disait voilà
que l'IRIS était un instrument
d'influence de la Chine.
D'accord. Et là, vous avez appelé la
DGSE et la DGSI en leur disant voilà
vous avez des fiches sur moi ou vous
faites pas votre
Non, j'ai juste demandé, j'ai téléphoné
au patron de l'IRSM quand j'ai su ça.
J'ai dis mais jeis bien voir ton rapport
sur quoi tu te bases ? Et après du coup
on a réécouté les trois colloques en
entier qu'on avait coorganisé où il y
avait des critiques sur la Chine, sur
les droits de l'homme, on parlait de
Taiwan et cetera. Donc c'était juste et
d'autres centres avaient fait des trucs
beaucoup plus à mon avis comprometts
avec les Chinois mais eux ils étaient
pas mis en cause. Non, c'est que on me
faisait payer mes positions disons euh
de
non occidentaliste.
Vous avez porté plainte parce que si si
laissez-moi terminer.
Si vous êtes en train de frayer
forcément les services de renseignement
vous reluc le fus sent la cyine au bout
du du de ce que vous avez au bout pour
savoir si vous êtes mouillé.
Oui. Bah ça aurait été le cas, ça
serait.
Et donc vous avez porté plainte ou pas ?
Ben non parce que vous savez la
diffamation c'est un peu compliqué et si
j'avais perdu mon procès, c'est un peu
d'une part bon à force les procéd en
diffamation c'est un budget aussi.
Vous avez perdu ?
Ouais. J'en ai perdu. Ouais. Ouais. Euh,
j'en ai gagné. J'en ai perdu. Bon, B
Life. Mais surtout, j'ai répondu en fait
bah j'ai ma mes propres réseaux de
communication, j'ai ma chaîne YouTube,
maintenant je suis sur TikTok, donc je
peux répondre. Et en fait, je réponds et
là bah les voilà, je mets les pieds dans
le plat et parfois c'est mieux que de
prendre une bonne douche. Ça fait du
bien et c'est très bien. Et donc et bien
sûr tous ces gens-là ont toujours refusé
tout débat contradictoire avec moi parce
que c'est ça qui est assez amusant
d'ailleurs tous ceux qui vous mordent
les molets ou vous attaquent les non
conservateurs les les purs et durs ceux
qui sont vraiment malintentionnés. Je
parle pas disons des gens qui pensent
sincèrement que l'Occident. Je parle de
ceux qui sont malintentionnés, ceux qui
vous mordent les molets, ceux qui vous
envoient des boules puantes en
permanence, ceux qui calomnient. Euh,
ils sont d'une mauvaise soie
épouvantable et surtout ils refusent
toujours le débat avec vous. Vous les
reconnaissez parce que il y a des gens
avec qui je suis en désaccord. Il y a
des gens qui sont occidentalistes, avec
qui je débats et c'est des débats de
bonne qualité. Voilà, c'est la
République, c'est la démocratie, on
n'est pas d'accord. Les autres t ta ta
les autres courage fuys acceptent pas le
débat parce qu'ils savent qu'ils ont pas
les moyens de le menervous parce que
après il y a le shadow banning qui vous
attend sur le réseau. Revenons revenons
à l'expérience de pensée et au conseil
auprès de nos politiques pour déterminer
une attitude ou un cap pour la France en
terme géopolitique. On en est où de
notre cap selon vous ?
Ah bah je sais plus trop s'il y en a un
parce que le en même temps euh fait
qu'il y a pas de cap.
C'est-à-dire que à la fois, il faut plus
livrer d'armes Israël et après on
s'excuse presse d'avoir dit ça
pour l'Ukraine aussi.
Et pour l'Ukraine effectivement, on
maintient le dial avec Poutine. Et
ensuite après le discours de Bratislava
de mémoire en mai 2023, le président de
la République prend le rôle du plus
grand soutien de Zelenski en Europe pour
jouer ce rôle-là. Euh et jusqu'à Mais
pour vous donner un point, par exemple,
à un moment donné, vous vous rappelez,
il avait dit peut-être qu'on pourrait
envoyer des soldats euh français euh en
Ukraine.
Je suis faré par ça. Euh je dis c'est
une formule, je veux pas mourir pour
Danzig et que vous savez, pendant toute
la guerre froide, on a soigneusement
évité qu'il y ait le moins de coup de
feu entre un soldat soviétique et un
soldat américain, entre un soldat de
l'OTAN et un soldat du pctevie. Donc si
vous vouz des soldats en Ukraine, il y
aura forcément c'est le risque d'une
première d'une 3e guerre mondiale. J'ai
pas envie de cela. Et que n'avais-je pas
dit tout de suite ? Bien sûr, ah c'est
Marcel de on le sait bien, c'est un
fachot, euh c'est un muniois. Alors le
l'argument du Mikois
à Noséam parce que dès que vous voulez
négocier vous êtes Muniquis, c'est
vraiment la paresse intellectuelle des
gens qui ne savent pas ce queétait par
ailleurs les accords de Milic mais c'est
la facilité et cetera et on vous
disqualifie puisque vous êtes un lâche.
Vous saz il y a beaucoup de churchill de
comptoir des gens qui veulent faire la
guerre mais enfin surtout les autres.
Des fois, je leur dis "Mais écoutez, il
y a peut-être un bureau d'embrigadement,
allez-y. En 36, les mecs, ils allaient
en Espagne se battre, ils allaient pas
les autres." Bon et donc en fait, vous
voyez bien que envoyer des soldats,
c'était irrationnel mais certains le
disaient. Disaient "Ben si, voilà, c'est
courageux, formidable, enfin une parole
ferme et cetera." Donc non, on a quand
même perdu une grande partie de la
crédibilité internationale.
L'ambiguité stratégique d'Emmanuel
Macron.
ce néounzu du 21e siècle, c'est pas un
peu un remix de la danse des canards ?
Alors là, je comprends pas tout à fait
la référence mais en tous les cas parce
qu'il fait juste coin coin ou bon euh
alors l'ambité stratégique ça peut être
utile mais là c'était pas une ambiguïté.
Là, on a sorti l'It pour rattraper une
erreur qui a été faite, pour rattraper
une conversation qui a peut-être un peu
dérapé parce que l'ambiguïté, c'est
justement de ne pas dire à l'avance ce
que l'on va faire mais pas dire qu'on
peut faire ça. Ça dire qu'on peut
envoyer des soldats c'est pas
l'ambiguïté. Et d'ailleurs, vous avez vu
que tout de suite et le président
américain et le chancier allemand ont
dit pas de salisette, hein. Donc c'est
que l'idée devait pas être aussi bonne
comme faire la grande coalition
internationale anti-has suggérée par
BHL. Enfin le fait, il y a eu quand même
alors on a fait un la visite au Maroc,
les médias ont fait un scandale parce
qu'il y avait Yassine Bellatar mais le
vrai scandale c'est qu'il a BHL ou non
de quoi il est dans la délégation. Enfin
c'est euh c'était assez amusant
d'ailleurs parce que les réseaux sociaux
protestaient contre la présence de
Bachel et les médias contre la présence
de Yassine Bellatar. Donc le fait de
faire une grande coalition antiamas, ça
a pas prospéré comme on dit quoi. Donc
non effectivement là moi je trouvais
qu'au départ Emmanuel Macon était
intéressant sur le plan international.
Il se réclamait du goulot mitérandis. Il
y avait une vision bon on peut pas dire
le le type est quand même intelligent,
il a une vision du monde et cetera.
Quand il a essayé de de rabibocher
Poutine à l'Europe en le faisant venir
au fort de Brégançon, en essayant de de
calmer les choses. Il était encore il
tenait la route à cette époque là. Oui,
mais la grande erreur en fait, c'est
qu'on a toujours fait pression sur
Petin, jamais sur les Ukrainiens pour
qu'ils mettent en route les accords de
de Minsk. Alors, les Russes les ont pas
respecté, mais pas plus les Ukrainiens,
ils les ont pas respecté ni l'un ni
l'autre. Et en fait, il y a un tournant,
c'est qu'il y a une réunion à Paris en
décembre 2019 où il y a Zelenski et
Poutine et il y a un accord. Il y a un
accord. On a rencontré Lavrov en marge
du forum pour la paix pour écouter ses
arguments.
Bon, il y a un accord et Selenski
revient à à Kiev et bah il y a des
pressions, il peut pas suivre l'accord
et cetera. Enfin bon, donc en fait
là, moi je trouve qu'en ce moment Macron
euh a pour en partie, en grande partie
ou en partie abandonné la posture
Golomitandis par souci de cohésion
européenne et donc de cohésion
occidentale
et donc de cohésion américaine. Ah bah
oui, parce que c'est eux qui sont les
patrons euh en Europe, d'autant plus que
disons que le le suivisme atlantiste a
été stimulé par l'agression russe de
l'Ukraine. Donc là, on va voir comment
il va faire avec euh Trump. Mais ce qui
a changé entre Trump 1 et Macron 1 et
Trump 2 et Macron 2, c'est
qu'entre-temps, vous en avez un qui est
survitaminé parce qu'il a tout raflé.
le vote populaire, les grands électeurs,
la Chambre des représentants, le Sénat
et plus la Cour suprême. Et il y en a un
autre qui affaibli pour les question de
politique intérieure. Quand vous êtes
faible en politique intérieure, c'est
plus difficile
d'avoir un leadership. Et là, la la
vague Trump arrive alors que l'Allemagne
est aux abonnés absents parce qu'ils
vont avoir des élections que Schol est
vraiment très affaibli,
c'est sa coalition a explosé parce que
son ministre des finances voulait pas
faire de dette.
Voilà. Donc la truc habituel des
libéraux. Bon effectivement et puis et
puis l'Allemagne est en crise
économique. C'est quand Merkel était
face à Trump, l'Allemagne
était en très bonne santé économique. Là
non, c'est plus le cas. Donc le rapport
de force a évolué une qualification.
Donc là, Macron, pour des raisons que
j'ai du mal à comprendre, à privilégier
la cohésion occidentale et européenne.
Il veut plus se faire engueuler par les
Polonais. Donc le le paris, si je le
comprends, tel qu'il m'a été expliqué,
c'est que il faut par les conseillers,
l'entourage, pas par le chef lui-même,
euh c'est le pari de dire "On s'est fait
engueuler par les pays-Baltes et les
Polonais, faut se réconcilier avec eux."
Oui, mais je pense qu'il faut pas
renoncer à être nous-même, surtout si on
pense que et je pense que la France en
tant que telle n'a pas à rentrer dans le
rang et que là on est en train de
manquer un tournant décisif, c'est que
le rôle de la France, c'est d'être le
pont entre le sud global, ce qu'on
appelait autrefois le Tiermond, ce qui a
fait très bien de Gaulle, le discours de
Mexico, Québec et tout ça, enfin Québec
cier monde mais donc c'était se
distinguer quand même le discours de Mom
Ben tout ça, Mitteran le discours de
Kangkoun et patin et Coufin et donc euh
Chirak aussi. Chirak effectivement le
refus de la guerre d'Irak et tout
les essais nucléaires.
Les essais alors les essais nucléaires.
Bon ça c'était plutôt une
un message aux Américains.
Oui enfin on aurait fait s'en passer
mais parce que ça été bon on a termé bon
c'est c'est autre chose. Toujours est-il
que la France a son ADN géopolitique
c'est d'être un pays occidental mais de
n'être pas que cela, d'être aussi un
pays allié mais aligné occidental mais
aussi ouvert sur le monde. Et si on
coupe nous-même nos ailes en renant sur
nos ailes pour se résumer, se réduire à
être juste un pays occidental, on perd
une grande partie de notre prestige. Il
fallait faire plus de choses avec les
Brésiliens, il fallait faire plus de
choses avec les Sud-Africains, sur la
Russie, sur Gaza, sur tout ça. Et non.
Et en fait là, bon et donc à partir du
moment où il faut pas
vexer les Néerlandais et les Polonais,
et ben il y a beaucoup moins de choses
que l'on peut faire parce que on est
minoritaire au sein de l'Europe sur nos
thèses. Donc bah on attend d'être
majoritaire mais on peut peut-être
attendre longtemps et donc bah on essaie
de trouver un truc et de faire des fois
de la surenchère activisme et on est en
train de louper quelque chose qui nous
aurait regardé notre attitude sur la
guerre de Gaza. Elle est pas dans la
lignée de Chirak avant 95 avant 2005
pardon. Après bon il a un peu rendu les
clés du camion. On parlera aussi des
gendarmes qui sont fait à
euh et de Mitteran et de Gaul bien sûr,
même de Giscar d'ailleurs. Donc et là
les pays du sud et au moment même où le
sud global prend une importance de plus
en plus grande,
bah on loupe ce virage là.
C'est le sud global qui prend une grande
importance ou c'est l'Occident qui
trébuche ?
C'est les vastes communiquants. C'est
les vastes communiquants. Le sud global
prend de plus en plus d'importendance.
la part, je dirais la part du monde
occidental diminue de façon évidente du
fait de la de l'émergence des autres, du
fait c'est l'effet secondaire de la
globalisation. Donc en fait l'Occident a
perdu le monopole de la puissance. Il a
pas perdu la puissance, il en a perdu le
monopole. L'Occident reste puissant,
l'Occident reste riche mais il a plus le
monopole. Mais vous avez des gens qui
veulent agir comme du temps du monopole.
Donc on prend les sanctions contre la
Russie, on va voir les pays africains
vont dire voilà on a décidé ça signé à
droite mais les mecs il disfument. C'est
il y a 20 ans, ils nous auraient suivi.
Il y a 20 ans, les pays latinoaméricains
auraient suivi les États-Unis
parce qu'ils avaient pas le choix.
Parce qu'ils avaient pas le choix.
Maintenant ils sont non seulement
indépendants mais ils sont aussi
s'ouvrs. Et donc au moment où le sud
global je sais bien que les n disent ça
n'existe pas, ils sont indifférents.
Ouais enfin il y a un truc qu'ils ont
tous en commun, c'est de plus accepter
un monde dirigé par l'Occident. Ça c'est
au moins le trait commun entre ceux qui
sont en confrontation avec l'Occident
comme la Russie, l'Iran et ceux qui sont
en coopération rivalité, la Chine mais
aussi le Brésil, l'Afrique du Sud et
cetera
et l'Inde.
Et l'Inde. Et donc on on là on avait
vraiment un boulevard pour nous. Moi, il
y a un exemple qui m'a choqué. On était
très content quand on a amené sommet du
G7, on invite grand et généreux quelques
pays du sud pour montrer que G7 est
ouvert et cetera. Et on est très content
parce qu'on a amené dans l'avion de la
République française Zelenski. Mais les
Brésiliens les autres, ils étaient
furieux en disant "Vous nous inviter
mais c'est encore pour nous parler de
l'Ukraine alors que vous savez qu'on
n'est pas d'accord et que vous voulez
nous imposer notre
votre agenda."
Loula avait menacé de ne pas venir au
sommet de Paris qui avait lieu quelques
temps après sur le partenariat financier
mondial si il fallait encore parler de
l'Ukraine. Donc il faut quand même voilà
ce sont des partenaires qu'on sur
lequels on pourrait jouer mais ils vont
pas venir sur nos positions. Faut aussi
qu'on fasse Chir qui avait réussi des
bons coups avec Loua, je veux dire au
début de ce siècle et donc là quand même
je pense que on d'accord, on est pas
d'accord sur tout mais il y aurait des
choses à faire qu'on ne tente pas trop.
Bon Trump a fait le grand chem et en
plus à le vote populaire.
Ouais
nous on a Macron avec un tout petit peu
plus de 15 % de taux d'adhésion.
On fait quoi avec ce leader
charismatique français ? On l'écoute, on
l'écoute pas, il parle dans le vent. il
attend il attend la fin de sa mandature.
Il va nous laisser les beau cassés entre
les 1000 milliards de dettes. Bruno le
maire et toute son administration
qui pratique très très bien le discours
plutôt que l'action.
Bah et j'espère en tous les cas que tant
qu'il est au pouvoir il fasse quelque
chose parce que on ne peut pas souhaiter
la disparition, l'inaction de la France.
Donc effectivement, il a affaibli sur le
plan de la politique intérieure, mais
rien ne pourrait l'empêcher de se
ressaisir sur le plan de la politique
extérieur, de trouver des choses
innovantes, de trouver des choses qui se
distinguent un peu. Mais sur le proche
Orient, on pourrait
C'est quoi vos propositions ? Et ben
effectivement à effectivement arrêter
d'envoyer parce qu'on peut pas réclamer
le cesser le feu et envoyer des armes.
C'est c'est quand même un peu bon et et
là je dire la la timidité de reconnaître
la Palestine. Alors les gens vous disent
on sert à rien, ça sert à rien. Mais
bizarrement les mêmes gens qui disent ça
sert à rien sont hyper agressifs quand
vous parlez de le faire. Donc ça doit
quand même servir à quelque chose. Sinon
ça exciterait pas à ce moment-là tous
ceux qui disent que ça sert à rien. Dès
que vous vous dites vous forquette la
Palestine les mecs là ils sont vent
debout et cetera. Bon, il y a quand même
quelques gestes symboliques que l'on
pourrait faire bah pour sauver notre
honneur, pour dire par rester muet par
rapport à ce qui se passe là quand même.
C'est grave ce qui se passe à Gaza.
C'est grave. Suffisamment grave pour
aller au tribunal pénal international.
Et bah ça, on verra on verra. Euh ce
c'est vrai que la Cour les les juges de
la Cour pénale internationale ont mis 3
semaines à se décider sur Poutine et là
ça fait au moins 3 mois qu'ils
attendent. Je sais pas si c'est une fake
news ou pas. Il y a une plainte pour
agression sexuelle contre le procureur.
Mais je sais du coup, j'ai pas eu le
temps de vérifier si c'est vrai ou si
c'est bon une sorte d'asse et cetera bis
et donc on voit bien que les juges sont
un peu plus timides parce qu'il y a des
pressions et avec Trump arrivant au
pouvoir déjà les Américains ont fait les
fortes pressions sur la cour pénale
internationale
qu' ne reconnaissent pas
et qu'ils ne reconnaissent pas qu'ils
ont pas de faire pression de les menacer
et cetera mais je dire
ils ont menacé à quel titre c'est pas
c'est c'estidement j
certains sénateurs qui ont écrit une
lettre pour dire que où c'est euh
Oui, il y a ça. Mais il y a aussi des
contacts directs. Il y a cet épisode où
le procureur doit voir l'ancien
président
euh de la RDC Kabila et en fait il se
retrouve avec un ministre israélien qui
lui va pas se passer comme ça ça ou non
avec un un pardon avec un un américain
qui lui dit mais ça va pas du tout comme
ça ça va pas se passer comme ça et
cetera. Donc il y a des fortes pressions
et je dire c'est très important la just
là il y a un recul du droit. Il y a un
recul du droit partout mais on peut pas
dire qu'on a des valeurs universelles et
piétiner le droit. Et on peut pas dire
que la courgè c'est uniquement pour les
africains. Je veux dire certains disent
on dit que avec l'inculpation des
leaders du Hamas et de Netaniaahu et de
Galan, la cour pénale s'était
déconsidérée. Elle se serait
déconsidérée si elle ne l'avait pas fait
clairement
euh parce que on peut pas dire que il y
a un tribunal uniquement pour les
Africains. C'était le cas dans les fêtes
quoi. Donc en fait il faut pas juger les
gens sur qu'ils sont mais sur ce qu'ils
font. Et donc oui, je sais bien qu'il
serait une démocratie, enfin une
démocratie quioccupe un autre peuple
quand même. Mais si il y a des crime de
guerre répertorié, il n'est pas
inenvisageable de saisir la cour pénale
internationale. Après, on verra ce qui
se passe.
L'Afrique du Sud l'a fait. Ouais. Alors
l'Afrique du Sud a non à la CP
internationale, c'est le procureur qui a
demandé l'inculpation
des trois leaders du Hamas qui sont tous
morts. Donc bon voilà, l'affaire est
close de ce côté-là, mais on pourrait en
inculper d'autres. et du premier
ministre et du ministre de la défense
israélien. L'Afrique du Sud a saisi la
coût en salle de justice
sur l'occupation et sur le fait que ça
avait les conséquences et pour Israël le
fait que ce soit l'Afrique du Sud le
pays qui a vaincu la partide et qui est
avec Israël le pays aussi disons auprès
duquel le monde avait une dette morale.
L'Afrique l'Afrique du Sud a pas
développé la bombe
israélienne. Non. Alors, il y avait une
coopération nucléaire entre ces deux
états paria dans les années 7080. Il y
avait eu en 79, on avait vu un flash
au-dessus du désert sud-africain parce
que on pouvait faire un essai en Afrique
du Sud, il y avait de la place, pas en
Israël. Et donc, il y a de forces assez
documentées sur le fait que l'Afrique du
Sud de la partelle et Israël avaient
coopéré ensemble sur le nucléaire. Et
lorsque la partelle a été démantelée,
l'Afrique du Sud a renoncé, a dit "Oui,
c'est vrai, on a une arme nucléaire et
donc on y renonce parce qu'en fait ils
avaient l'arme nucléaire parce qu'ils
étaient comme Israël entourés d'ennemis
plus nombreux pour se protéger. À partir
du moment où ils font leur paix avec les
voisins parce qu'il dément de la
partide, ils n'ont plus besoin de l'arme
nucléaire.
Sur sur le fait que les la cour pénale
internationale reçoivent des pressions,
la France se positionne comment par
rapport à ça ? Alors, il faut
reconnaître que alors que d'autres pays
ont dit "Non, c'est pas normal, la
France s euh a euh défendu en disant
"Nous nous sommes nous sommes membres de
la Cour pé internationale et elle n'a
pas condamné comme d'autres pays ont
condamné cette saisie en disant que
c'était inconvenant de mettre en
accusation le premier ministre
israélien." Vous savez, des pays
occidentaux qui ont dit "C'est pas
normal, c'est une démocratie." J'adore
cet argument. Enfin, je veux dire, une
fois encore, on juge pas la nature,
c'est pas un cours de droit
constitutionnel, c'est un cours de droit
international. Donc, on juge pas la
nature de régime politique, on juge son
comportement à l'égard de ses voisins et
d'autres peuples. Donc, c'est le droit
international. Voilà. Bon, et donc là,
la France là-dessus qui n'a pas toujours
été très courageuse sur le dossier
là-dessus, bon, ils n'ont pas été les
responsables français n'ont pas été en
contradiction avec eux-mêmes sur le
dossier de la CPI.
Les juges de la CPI sont nommés comment
?
Alors, ils sont nommés pour 9 ans. Il y
a un système détail représente et
cetera. J'ai plus le détail en tête. Je
sais pas si c'est Je sais que mes vieux
souvenirs de droit, c'est que la courie
sont 15 nommés par les États, les
groupes d'État et ils sont normalement
non renouvelables, ce qui doit assurer
leur indépendance. et la CPI, il y a des
quand même des tractus, des tractations
entre États, ils doivent être
représentatifs bah de je des pays membre
quand même. Donc doit y avoir une
diversité.
Qu'est-ce que le droit international
face au droits bibliques ? Quand on voit
certains ministres israériens dire "Non,
on fait pas d'occupation parce que c'est
notre terre."
C'est clair. C'est clair. On va pas
changer le cadastre. Si euh vous savez,
il y a cette vous avez dû voir un type
qui arrive en angla une femme qui arrive
en Angleterre, elle sonne, elle voit dit
"Oui, vous savez bonjour en fait, je
viens habiter chez vous." Ah bon ?
Pourquoi ? Bah voilà, je suis romaine et
puis euh tant de siècle, on était ici
donc on va revenir. Enfin bon, voilà.
Effectivement, je veux dire si vous
jugez le conflit au nom de critères
religieux sortira jamais.
Les Iraniens vont demander des bouts
d'Inde.
C'est ce qu'avait effectivement répondu
un ministre à François Fillon une fois
en disant effectivement donc bon il y
avait quand même un accord qui était
raisonnable qui était que les
Palestiniens acceptaient de ne créer
leur état que sur 22 % de la Palestine
mandataire donc hérité de l'Empire
ottoman. Au départ, le partage c'est 55
45. 55 pour Israël, 45 pour les
Palestiniens. Alors qu'Israël ne fait
qu'à l'époque que 30 % 35 % de la
population. Les Arabes refusent ça en
disant "Bah en fait nous on était chez
nous et vous nous faites payer le prix
de vos propres crimes parce que la choix
c'est pas nous, c'est vous." Et donc on
accepte pas. Mais Israël gagne la
première guerre, il les étendent leur
territoire de 55 à 78 %. C'est la Nagba.
les Palestiniens au bout de longtemps,
bon disons c'est Arafat quand il vient à
Paris en 89 qui accepte que l'État
palestien ne soit créé que sur les 22 %
restants. C'est quand même raisonnable.
C'est quand même raisonnable. Et
effectivement le Hamas refuse ça. Donc
commet des attentats et le camp de la
paix en Israël a disparu sous les
cousamas qui faisaient des attentats
suicides qui révulsaient les Israéliens
et les assassins de rabine
dans les bus avec des cocottes minut
civil.
et les assassins de rabines qui sont
aujourd'hui au pouvoir.
Pourquoi vous dites que les assassins de
rabin sont au pouvoir ?
Bah
font partie de ceux qui appelaient qui a
la danation de Rabine en disant c'est
pas ils ont pas fait l'assassinat. Non
mais disons qu'ils ont été les enfin je
crois que c'est Ben Vir qui a voulu
arracher
un truc sur la voiture de Rabine et il
faisait partie de mouvement qui
appelaient à la disparition de Rabine.
Vous avez bon la veuve de Rabine Rabine
n'a plus jamais voulu serrer la main de
Sharon et Tananyaahou parce qu'ils
allaient dans des meetings où on
appelait à la mort de Rabine et qui
disait pas non taisez-vous faites pas
ça. Rabine a été
comment déguisé en soldat nazi, en fédaï
tout ce que vous voulez. Donc bon, c'est
il y a vraiment là quand même des
il a été tué pas par un palen par un
extrémiste et disons que ceux qui sont
au pouvoir sont les héritiers politiques
de ceux qui ont tué rabine. Bon et et
donc je ne sais pas si on retrouvera, je
ne suis pas sûr que la solution à deux
états soit encore viable. Qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire de Gaza ? Qu'est-ce qu'on
va faire de Gaza ? En fait, il y a c'est
plus vivable. Donc soit il y a une
nettoyage ethnique massif, soit quoi ?
Qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire ? Ça fait
quand même plus d'un an que il y a des
gens qui peuvent pas aller à l'école,
peuvent pas prendre une douche, comment
ils font pour leurs besoins alimentaires
pour se nourrir au bord de la famille ?
OK, le 7 octobre, j'ai condamné les
intérêts tout de suite. Mais quand quand
les gens disent "Mais en fait Israël et
l'Ukraine sont les deux pays qui ont été
agressés, mais si l'Ukraine avait fait
autant de dégâts en Russie qu'Israël en
a fait à Gaza, je crois pas qu'on aurait
été proinien. Donc euh si l'Ukraine
avait tué des millions de Russes et bon
et je veux dire en plus moi j'avais fait
un bouquin sur la guerre en Ukraine qui
est sorti le 30 août 2023 pour qu' un
peu tout ce sens critique et notamment
je disais
vous vous parliez de votre vous faisiez
votre truc critique dedans
Oui oui oui oui bien sûr j'ai pas de
souci avec ça vous savez et et non mais
surtout je disais il y a du de poids de
mesure parce que en fait les mêmes qui
disent il faut aider l'Ukraine parce
qu'elle a été agressée parce que la
Russie ce n'est pas normal d'attaquer
des territoires et de les occuper par la
force. Ce n'est pas normal de bomber les
civiles. Oui, moi aussi je le dis. Et
les mêmes quand c'est Israël qui le
fait, disons bah ils vont fumer une
clope dehors et ils s'occupent de rien.
Donc c'est et et en plus là on bombarde
des gens qui sont soumis à un blocus.
Des bombardants au civil, c'est un crime
de guerre sur toutes les lois de la
terre. Mais là en plus soumis un blocus.
Les gens, nouvel argument, c'est c'est
dingue. Les nombre d'arguments disent
"Oui, mais en fait pour gagner une
guerre, bah voilà, c'est dommage, il
faut tuer." Les les gens qui disent
"Vous savez, je souffre pour les mères
palestiniennes, je souffre pour ell mais
voilà, on va les libérer du Hamas et
c'est vraiment tuer les toutes du
reconnaîtra les siens. On va aller liber
Hamas et de toute façon, regardez
Coventry, regardez Dress, regardez les
bombardements." Mais c'est justement
après la seconde guerre mondiale qu'on a
fait un droit humanitaire. Je les gens
justifient des crimes de guerre par des
périodes qui sont antérieures à les la
consolidation du droit inter
humanitaire. C'est c'est vraiment des
arguments et quand vous entendez ça et
ça passe quand même sur beaucoup de
plateaux. Il serait une démocratie donc
ils ont le droit. Il faut gagner la
guerre, il y a pas de d'omelett sans
casser les œufs. Euh oui, c'est dommage.
Et ce que je supporte plus, c'est ceux
qui viennent avec des larmes de
crocodile en faisant semblant de pleurer
sur le sang des pasciens dont ils n'ont
rien à battre et dont peut-être même ils
se réjouissent euh de leur mort.
Est-ce que vous connaz connaissez la
notion d'arithmétique de la rébellion ?
Alors en fait, vous en avez parlé dans
un épisode récent, c'est 2 ans avec le
général Didier Castre.
Non, mais vous avez recité ça aussi. Et
oui, c'est queen fait bah c'est le cycle
répression action quoi.
C'est le cycle si je bombarde un
terroriste et que pour une bonne cause
et que j'attrape son cousin, sa tante,
le de petit neveux, le voisin du cousin,
ainsi de suite, ça m'en fait 10
derrière. Bien sûr, mais tous les
militaires vous disent ça. Tous les
militaires, vous savez, souvent les les
militaires sont plus enfin dans les
plateaux par quelques-uns qui sont très
anti idéologiquement. Mais généralement
vousz souvent les militaires dire on
fait pas la guerre sans but politique,
ça sert à rien.
Voilà,
c'est la politique, la guerre,
l'extension.
J'ai relu enfin j'avais retrouvé parce
que je l'avais lu en 76, j'étais
étudiant à Science Po à l'époque dans 3è
cycle. avait fait lire Raymond Aaron
avait fait un bouquin sur Clositz
et dedans il écrit la chose suivante
Israël poursuit des objectifs
stratégiques qu'il gagne grâce à sa
puissance militaire je paraaphrase c'est
pas tout à fait ça mais qu'il l'empêche
d'atteindre ses ses objectifs politiques
et Roon n'était pas insensible au sort
d'Israël donc Israël gagne des guerres
mais comme il y a pas d'objectif c'est
quoi l'objectif politique là sur Gaza
on a du mal sauf à continuer la guerre
pour rester au pouvoir. et pour que les
deux excités ne quittent pas la
coalition.
Récupérer les otages peut-être.
Bah en fait ça apparemment il a mieux
fallu négocier hein. Donc il y a quand
même il y avait un accord qui a été
signé qui a été abandonné parce que
Netaniaou voulait garder le contrôle du
couloir de Philadelphie et Biden lui en
a voulu mais rien dit. Il y a des
Israéliens qui ont très largement
documenté le fait que les otages
auraient pu être libérés qu'un accord
avait été trouvé par le Hamas et que
c'est Nathanou qui a fait capoter
l'affaire. Le seul moment où des otages
ont été libérés, c'est quand il y a eu
une négociation sous l'Égypte du Qatar
et cetera. Euh et là on voit bien que je
sais pas combien il reste d'otage, mais
plus ceux qui ont été tués en voulant
les libérer et cetera. Donc euh
le Qatar est en train de se retirer de
sa médiation. Non s'est retiré de sa
médiation.
Il annoncé qu'il allait se retirer parce
que en fait personne veut négocier en
réalité.
C'est peut-être qu'il y a plus d'otage.
Non, je pense qu'il y en a encore. On
sait pas combien effectivement. On sait
pas combien sont en vie surtout.
Et dans quel état ?
Bon et dans quel état mais effectivement
ils ont été sacrifiés. Ils ont été
sacrifiés. C'est quoi la directive
Annibale ? Ah bah c'est euh en fait de
tout raser euh pour que ça ne enfin
vraiment de faire table ras quoi de dire
ah non de canbal c'est autre chose c'est
si quelqu'un est pris en otage bah on
c'ester sausé quoi. Vous vous rappelez
dans Keer Sausé pour montrer que il
craint rien. Il tue son fils par rapport
à un mec. Il flingue son fils pour
montrer qu'il a peur de rien. Et donc
là, vous avez un otage. Bah vous tuez
l'otage pour qu'il ne soit pas otage
et que on puisse pas vous faire chanter
et pour dire ça marchera pas. En réalité
les Israéens ont toujours jusqu'ici
sensibles aux otages. Des fois ils ont
libéré des gens uniquement pour
récupérer la la vie d'un soldat
israélien et même la
pour libérer des des milliers de de
détenus palestiniens.
Oui. Et ils ont aussi même des choix
pour simplement récupérer le cadavre de
soldats morts en opération. Ils ont
libéré des gens. Donc c'est quand même
nouveau là de de ne pas prendre en
considération comme cela les otages.
Alors une fois encore, c'est le Hamas
qui a fait prisonnier bien sûr. Euh mais
il y a aussi des prisonniers
palestiniens. On nous dit on nous dit
non mais il faut pas confondre il y a
des otages et des prisonniers. Mais a
des prisonniers palestiniens qui ne sont
pas jugés, qui ont été arrêtés euh de
façon sans qu'on dise ce quoi on les
accusait, qui sont emprisonnés, qui
parfois sont quand même maltraités. Il a
des images là-dessus. Il y a des
rapports de Betsem, une assoation
israélienne admirable de défense des
droits de l'homme. Voilà. D'ailleurs, la
France pourrait aussi plus s'appuyer sur
les pacifices israéliens, sur Betsélem.
On les pas tellement on a peur de fâcher
le gouvernement israélien en s'appuyant
sur eux parce qu'ils sont mis un peu sur
la liste noire du gouvernement. Donc en
fait, il y a il y a aussi des
prisonniers pal il y a des prisonniers
palestiens qui ont été jugés et qui
peuvent être condamnés parce qu'ils ont
commis des actions violentes contre les
citoyens israéliens. Mais il y en a qui
sont emprisonnés sur le soupçon de faire
quelque chose et donc c'est pas
documenté. C'est bon
un peu comme à Guantanamo, non ?
Pardon ?
Un peu comme à Guantanamo.
Alors certains parlent d'un Guantanamo
israélien dans cette prison dans le
désert où il y a eu effectivement des
viols, des mauvais traitements et
cetera. Mais effectivement on prend des
gens qu'on emprisonne sur la base de
soupçon et qui n'ont pas le droit à un
jugement et on peut les garder en prison
6 mois sans qu'ils soient jugés et même
plus puisqu'on peut renouveler.
Revenons à Trump.
Trump et cet échec médiatique occidental
de pas l'avoir vu monter.
Si si si quand même beaucoup de gens
l'ont vu monter et les gens disaient
alors bon dire que c'est coup à coude
alors que c'est un land slide pour lui
on peut dire que c'est une erreur mais
quand même regardez Camalaris est partie
très très fort et très vite elle a
patiné parce qu'elle a pas imprimé parce
qu'elle a pas fait la différence qu'elle
a été investie trop tard et en fait
qu'elle a été investie sur désignation
du chef chancelant et pas sur vote des
électeurs. Enfin rien ne s'est bien
passé dans cette campagne. vraiment bon,
elle avait pas imprimé pendant 4 ans de
vice-présidence, bah elle a pas imprimé
en 3 mois. Tout le monde a été rassuré
parce que effectivement par rapport à
Biden, elle marchait normalement, elle
se cassait pas la gueule tous les 3 m et
elle confondait pas Poutine et
vous êtes méchant. Biden se cassait pas
la la binette tous les 3 m.
Bah en tous les cas quand même
il marchait comme un champion olympique
qui avait un Parkinson.
Ouais. et on peut pas dire quand même
que euh il y avait pas une faiblesse de
connaissance de une faiblesse cognitive
quoi. Donc il a bon alors donc on s'est
dit formidable, il a abandonné en fait,
il a abandonné sur la pression de ses
amis et Camel Harris présentait bien
mais le seul fait je dire avoir pour
slogan un not going back ne suffit pas à
mobiliser et le fait de dire je suis
femme et métisse ne pas suffit il
fallait qu'elle propose quelque chose à
la jeunesse qu'elle mobilise 10 millions
de voix de moins que Biden en 2020
10 ou 12
alors 10 au début c'était 12 Mais en
fait, il y a des votes qui sont arrivés
après qui ont été comptés après. C'est
entre les deux en tous les cas. Donc en
fait, elle a été battue par
l'abstention. Elle a été battue par les
gens qui se sont dit bah blanc bonet,
bonnet blanc
parce que Trump a fait 2 millions de
moins que
que que lui-même en 2020 et Camala donc
entre 10 et 12 que Biden en 2020. Donc
c'est énorme. C'est énorme. Et
effectivement euh je pense que le fait
qu'elle ne se s'est pas distingué alors
bon sur l'avortement elle a mobilisé
mais elle a aussi effrayé une partie du
public latino qui était pas pour et qui
aurait été pour elle sinon mais euh je
veux dire économiquement qu'est-ce
qu'elle a proposé et cetera. Euh il y a
je dire it's économiste stupide c'est
vraiment ça compte les gens qui ont du
mal à se loger et le fait queir à
soigner
à se soigner effectivement et puis je
pense que Gilstin qui est la candyade
juive c'est marrant parce qu'en fait
c'est les plus critiques d'Israël aux
États-Unis c'est deux juifs c'est Bernie
Sanders et Jilstein candidate verte elle
a fait en tout au niveau national un peu
moins de 700000 voix donc c'est pas elle
qui a fait perdre Camalaris parce que
dans aucun swing stats l'addition
Camalaris et Gilistine ne dépassaient
Donald Trump mais c'est l'abstention qui
a fait perdre comme il Lindon en 2016.
Qu'est-ce qui va nous faire Trump avec
l'Ukraine ? Qu'est-ce qu' va nous faire
Trump avec Israël ? Et qu'est-ce que
Trump va nous faire surtout avec la
Chine ?
Alors c'est trois questions différentes
sur l'Ukraine. Il a annoncé la couleur.
Son fils a tweeté "C'est fini l'argent
de poche pour Zelenski", ce qui est pas
très diplomatique mais ce qui est assez
direct. Euh on lui on a dit à Zelenski
"Mais si tu penses que tu vas récupérer
la Crimée, tu rêves." Mais en fait, vous
savez, moi ça fait 1 an et demi que j'ai
dit que les budgas de Zelenski sont
irréalistes. J'étais amoral. J'étais un
suppos de Poutine de dire ça récupérer.
Il y a quand même des choses simples. Il
y a cin fois moins d'Ukrainiens que de
Russes. Comme on va pas envoyer de
soldat parce qu'on veut pas la trème
guerre mondiale et qu'en plus Poutine
d'arme nucléaire donc on n'ira pas le
chercher à Moscou pour l'envoyer devant
le tribunal de la il va garder les
territoires et on le sait depuis un an
et demi.
qui ont
bah en fait moi tous les militaires
américains, les militaires américains le
disent, les militaires français vous le
disent que bon mais effectivement
les astrologues de plateau télé non
et ben non parce que c'est pas moral
parce que en fait c'est vraiment la
moralisme de la moraline. Si vous dites
ça, la réelle politique c'est pas bien
mais le fait de d'envoyer des gens
mourir pour ne rien changer parce qu'en
fait on c'est évident que il va pas
récupérer les territoires. poursuivre la
guerre, c'est juste faire des morts de
plus, des blessés, des mutilés de plus,
des gens qui vont perdre et cetera. Tout
ça pour dire alors les gens disent notre
crédibilité stratégique est en jeu. On
l'a engagé parce qu'on a donné les clés
du camion à Zelenski en disant "C'est
vous qui desserez le fin de la guerre,
on envoie des armes, on envoie du pognon
et on n'a pas de prise sur la décision."
Et c'est c'est quand même assez
hallucinant tout ça parce que
effectivement les Ukrainiens ont les
mêmes voitures que nous et que Poutine a
agressé l'Ukraine, qu'il faut la
défendre. Mais il aurait fallu qu'on
réfléchisse à nos intérêts. Donc en fait
le fait que
c'était quoi nos intérêts ?
Ah bah de comment déjà éviter cette
guerre au départ en faisant pression et
c'est également sur les ukrainiens pour
qu'ils acceptent qu' mettent un peu en
place les accords de Minsk. Ne pas
donner à la Russie le sentiment qu'elle
ne comptait pas et cetera. Et puis bon,
une fois que la guerre a commencé,
effectivement là, il faut venir aider
l'Ukraine, mais on peut fixer les
objectifs, dire "On vous aide jusqu'à
temps, on fait on fait de telle manière,
voilà ce que l'on peut faire, voilà ce
qu'on ne peut pas faire." Là en fait, on
était taxé sans être représenté parce
que c'est décidé entre Zelmiki et
Washington, pas avec nous, on avait pas
prise sur la décision donc c'est quand
même une impuissance volontaire. Donc en
fait Trump va arrêter l'aide. il va
demander, il a demandé à Poutine de ne
pas pousser son avantage qui est assez
malin en disant parce qu'il il a compris
que si Poutine lance une grande
offensive et arrive à Odessa, ça va. Je
ce qu'il faudrait l'objectif c'est une
ukraine viable
donc qui a toujours accès à la mer qui a
des garanti de sécurité réelle mais le
Donbas dont beaucoup d'Ukrainiens se
foutaient d'ailleurs avant la guerre
restera russe. Restera russe.
J'ouvre une parenthèse.
Est-ce qu'on n'est pas en train de voir
on va faire une expérience de pensée
encore. Est-ce qu'on est pas en train de
voir en fait une une guerre pour des
ressources déguisées ?
Côté russe ? Ils veulent le Donbas pour
le lithium.
côté européen, on veut le Donbas pour le
lithium à travers l'Ukraine dans l'OTAN.
Est-ce que on n'est pas en train de
jouer
l'OTAN l'Ukraine ne rentrera jamais dans
l'OTAN parce que les États-Unis s'y
opposeront toujours.
Et quand quand le secrétaire général de
l'OTAN dit "Bon, si Trump arrête son
aide, je serais personnellement le
premier à expulser les États-Unis de
l'autre."
Non mais il plaisante. Enfin, c'est une
plaisanterie de garçon de bain. Le secrè
général de l'OTAN, il a des éléments de
langage qui dit la même chose.
Il est élu cet hommelà ou il est pas élu
? Comment ça se passe ?
Bah, il est désigné par les membres de
l'alliance. Euh donc ça a été Stenbank
très longtemps qui était un type
remarquable avant de devenir secrétaire
journal de l'OTAN. C'est-à-dire que il a
eu un comportement remarquable quand il
était premier ministre norvégien après
les intern de d'Outaka où il a dit on va
être plus démocrate, on va vraiment il
est pas sombré dans la folie antitoris
et ensuite il a été avalé par le
conformisme otanien et là Marc Routeux
bah vient de prendre le job il est
néerlandais donc très atlantiste
nationalement il vient de prendre le job
et donc effectivement il se dit si les
se barrent bah ma côte part elle va
baisser mais les États se barront pas
les se barront pas dans l' temps parce
qui sont pas pour nous, ils sont pour
eux. Ils vont juste nous demander de
payer plus. Donc vous savez que depuis
2023, depuis le début de la guerre,
pardon, 63 % des achats d'armes des pays
européens en dehors de même ont été
faits aux États-Unis
et un peu en Corée aussi, un peu en
Israël et moins entre nous pays
européens. Donc euh quand euh le le
quand Trump dit que l'OTAN lui coûte
cher, non, c'est très largement compensé
par les acquisitions d'équipement
militaires américains par les pays
européens.
Puis on a acheté un peu de gaz aussi,
hein.
Et plus effectivement la la distorsion
de concurrence et le fait d'accepter les
flashion qui est un aspirateur à
investissement européen. On a quand même
perdu le rapport Dragy est très net mais
malheureusement on n fera rien. On a
perdu 20 % de compétitivité depuis 15
ans par rapport aux États-Unis. Et là
effectivement c'est quand même très
problématique. Mais donc l'Ukraine
rentrera pas dans le temps parce que les
États-Unis démocrates comme républicain
s'y opposeront tant qu'il y aura une
guerre. On fait pas rentrer un pays en
guerre dans une alliance défensive qui
nous oblige à aller en guerre. Ce qu'on
peut proposer c'est un moratoire de 20
ans sur Ralisons le temps. En fait la
grande erreur c'est en 2008 parce que on
fait une double erreur. Les américains
veulent à tout prix faire rentrer
l'Ukraine dans l'OTAN. C'est la doctrine
Pinski sans l'Ukraine, la Russie cesse
d'être un empire européen et Merkel et
Sarkozis oppose. Le compromis, il est
complètement bancal, c'est qu'on dit
oui, l'Ukraine a vocation d'entrer dans
l'OTAN, ce qui effrait la Russie. C'est
la ligne rouge pour Poutine le dit
depuis le début et en même temps comme
nous on veut pas qu'il rentre, il n'y
rentre pas. Donc ils ont vocation
rentrée, ils sont dangereux pour la
Russie mais ils sont pas membres de
l'OTAN, donc ils sont pas protégés. Donc
effectivement, ils ont cette fragilité
là.
En terme de guerre économique, attendez
avant de passer à la guerre économique,
on va parler guerre tout court. Poutine,
si on lui laisse le donbas, les
territoires annexés, la Crimé et tout
ça, est-ce qu'il va s'en satisfaire ?
Est-ce que est-ce que est-ce que là là
parce que bon, vous êtes jamais battu
avec un SPnas dans un bar vous ? Non,
non, pas encore.
Non, ben je vous conseille, ça devrait
être conseillé à tous nos diplomates, ça
leur remettrait les yeux en face des
trous. Donc là, on l'a bien énervé.
On l'a tellement énervé qu'il fait
copaincopains avec les les nordéens,
il a refondé toute son économie en mode
économie de guerre. Vous savez que quand
on a une économie de guerre, l'économie
de guerre demande de plus en plus de
sang pour rester en position. Et on se
retrouve avec une économie allemande
exang. Ils veulent pas l'avouer mais les
Allemands sont cuits. La France fait ce
qu'elle peut pour essayer de pas boire
la tasse entièrement.
On a l'Europe complètement affaiblie, on
a plus d'énergie.
S'il nous coupe le gaz, si nous coupe le
pétrole, si nous coupe l'uranium, si
nous coupe le titane, si nous coupe tout
ça, on sera réduit à faire Mikeland pour
touristes chinois.
Est-ce qu'il va s'arrêter ? Parce que
là, on lui a quand même bien cassé les
oignons là, résister.
Ouais, ouais, ouais. Alors, deux choses
par rapport à votre question. La
première, l'Alliance à Claorée du Nord,
ça rend furieux les Chinois.
Ça
c'était leurs copains.
Non, c'est leur honte. Ils ont honte des
nord coréens. Mais
les Chinois, ils ont pas du tout honte
des nord-coréens. C'est il vend le fou à
la chinoise.
Non non non, ils leur font honte parce
que vous savez les nord-coréens pour les
Chinois, c'est comme le tonton qui fait
partie de la famille qu'on est obligé
d'inviter au mariage mais que tout le
monde craint qu'il divague et qu'il
fasse honte à tout le monde. Parce que
bon, les Chinois ont dit au
nord-coréens, faites comme nous, gardez
le pouvoir et ouvrez l'économie. Et en
fait ils ont ils peuvent pas supporter
l'effondrement de la Corée du Nord parce
que sinon c'est des soldats américains à
leur frontière.
Donc ils trouvent qu'ils ont déconné
mais ils peuvent pas les laisser tomber.
Et l'alliance entre la Corée du Nord et
la Russie a eu pour effet de réconcilier
Japonais Sud-Coréens qui jusqu'ici
s'engueulaient copieusement pour des
questions mémorielles. Et donc en fait
le le renforcement américain en Asie, le
renforcement de la coopération Corée du
Sud, Japon, États-Unis et le contre-coup
de l'alliance Corée du Nord Russie. Donc
les Chinois sont furieux mais en même
temps ils peuvent rien faire parce que
ils peuvent pas lâcher Poutine faute de
quoi ils ont un régime procidental à
leur frontière. Ils peuvent pas lâcher
Kim Jongun parce que pour les mêmes
raisons mais ils sont pas contents avec.
Alors votre deuxème question, est-ce que
Poutine va continuer ? En fait s'il ne
commet pas la même erreur qu'il a
commise en lançant la guerre, il empoche
ses bénéfices. Il a quand même besoin
d'arrêter la guerre. Il y a quand même
beaucoup de morts. Il y a quand même des
familles qui commencent à râer. Il a des
élections législatives dans 2026. Je
sais que ça sert à rien mais
formellement ça sert. Et donc il peut
vouloir dire voilà et j'ai obtenu un
accord. Les droits de la Russie
éternelle ont été reconnus par les
États-Unis. Ni les États-Unis, ni la
France, ni personne ne reconnaîtra
jamais l'annexion de la Crimée.
D'ailleurs, même la Chine ne reconnaît
pas l'annexion de la Crimée. Et bon,
mais on peut avoir un cesser le feu sans
reconnaître cela. Et donc il peut se
dire bah je m'en sors à bon compte parce
que continuer la guerre à force
même en martyrisant ma population même
en faisant une sorte de régime stalinien
sans le goulac de masse ça va quand même
finir un peu par raller. Donc bon s'il
alors s'il dit bah je vais continuer
jusqu'à au dess et cetera, là ça nous
obligerait à réagir plus fortement et
effectivement là à ne pas accepter.
Guerre économique,
on l'a vu venir, on était prêt, on était
pas prêt. Est-ce qu'on a des cellules de
guerre économique qui ont correctement
conseiller notre grand ministre des
finances, Bruno Lemer ?
Bah, on l'a pas tout à fait vu venir
parce que alors c'est vrai qu'il y a des
lourdeurs européennes
dont on n'est pas forcément comptable,
mais regardez le rapport Dragy, il est
assez réaliste mais il va pas être mis
en œuvre
parce que vous avez les États frugaux
qui disent "Non, pas de dépense et
cetera." On avait au sommet de Lisbonne
2000 ou 2001 dit on sera les maîtres de
l'autoroute de la formation. On n quête
pas à la traine. 70 % de des recettes de
l'IA vont être partagé entre la Chine et
les États-Unis. Il va nous rester quoi ?
Donc effectivement, c'est là où l'Europe
est aussi un frein parce que le ministre
des finances allemands a démissionné
pour ça. Ils veulent pas s'endetter, ils
veulent pas faire de dettes communes et
cetera et donc oui, on est en guerre
économique. On est en guerre économique
contre les États-Unis. On est des alliés
stratégiques, mais on est des rivaux
économiques. Trump a au moins le mérite
de la franchise. Biden nous a endormi en
disant vous êes je quand Biden a été
élu, on était vraiment soulagé en disant
"Ah, génial, on revient." qui ont
nos dirigeants,
c'est qui on s'est fait endormir
alors les commentateurs et les
dirigeants, grosso modo parce que disons
le thème général, pas universel mais le
thème général c'est à le retour à un
président américain atlantiste qui sait
ce que c'est que l'Europe et cetera mais
quand il lance l'inflation Dion Act,
vous savez je quand Biden a été élu, il
y a eu une réunion au Korsais, c'était
en en visio parce qu'à l'époque il y a
était encore le le covid donc pas voir
d'ors c'est quoi c'est le bowling dans
les là affaires étrangères et
c'est là où il y a le dormeur
voilà alors donc le secrétaire général
du quai qui un type très bien réunit une
demiine 7 h dirigeants de fingtong pour
dire bon faire une sorte d'évaluation
commune que faire avec Biden comment
relance ta machine et cetera
et moi je dis bah il y a donc l'espoir
du multilateralisme renouvelé et moi je
dis bah ça m il y a quand même un doute
général quand même bon et cetera. Moi je
dis bah il y a un test très simple, il y
a qu'à leur demander d'arrêter
l'application extraterritoriale de leur
législation parce que si vous êtes
allié, vous n'allez pas punir les 40
milliards que les boîtes européennes ont
payé au trésor américain. Et là on vous
a dit "Vous croyez au père Noël ?" Non
non, on m'a dit "Ah non, ça on peut
pas." Pas pas le scratchet, mais un de
mes collègues m'a dit "Non, ça on peut
pas, ça on peut pas." qui Ah non non
non, je le dirai pas euh parce que
c'était une réunion privée et cetera
mais il était représentatif, il était
terrorisé,
c'était pas terrorisé mais c'est il il
pensait que ça valait même pas la peine
d'essayer parce que et cetera parce que
c'était peine perdue parce que on se
heurtait. C'est l'impuissance
volontaire. C'est l'impuissance
volontaire.
Une
petite question internet entre-temps
histoire de s'aérer. Alors, bonjour et
merci pour votre temps. Comment perce
comment percevez-vous l'avenir de la
France au sein de l'Union européenne ?
Première question. Et de la même
personne. Comment percevez-vous l'avenir
de la France à l'international ?
Bah, au sein de l'Union européenne, il
ferait qu'on retrouve un rôle un peu
plus moteur, mais il est vrai que
lesichements successifs ont un peu dilué
notre influence. La France n'a pas les
mêmes capacités d'entraînement. euh dans
une Europe à 27 que dans une Europe à 12
ou à 15. Non mais regardez, on va
regarder. Je vous coupe, je suis désolé
parce qu'on se connaitt un petit peu
même si on n'est pas d'accord sur tout.
On peut on peut se s'échanger des
chaises.
L'Allemagne va calencher. Il faut être
très clair. L'Allemagne c'est l'homme
malade de de l'Europe. Oui.
Leur industrie leur industrie hyper
spécialisée, hyper consommatrice
d'énergie
sans le gaz russe, ils sont condamnés à
faire quoi ? À faire des saucisses et du
jambon de la forêt noire. Non, mais ils
font des trucs moins compétitifs. Ils
vont continuer à faire des bagnoles, à
faire de la chimie, à faire de des
machines outils et cetera, mais ils
seront moins compétitif parce que c'est
plus cher simplement.
Donc, ils seront moins compétitifs. Et
là, la France arrive avec son parc
nucléaire
et va mettre l'Allemagne au pas et on va
reprendre notre leadership. Non,
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
On l'a abandonné quand même he beaucoup
sur le nucléaire. Ça nous a à coûté
quand même parce
que les Allemands nous ont fait des
crocheptes.
Oui, mais il y a aussi on a aussi pour
la raison intérieure enfin c'est pas
seulement c'est on a pas abandonné le
nucléaire à la demande des Allemands
mais ils nous ont pas aidé, ils nous ont
pas facilité la tâche. On a quand même
quelques sujets de fâcherie avec les
Allemands et donc là il y a quand même
un pays qui est intéressant en ce moment
c'est l'Espagne. On pourrait beaucoup
plus jouer avec. Ils sont mobiles, ils
sont indépendants, ils ont augmenté le
pouvoir d'achat et cetera. Euh il faut
pas qu'on s'enferme dans un modèle
franco-allemand dont les Allemands euh
je veux dire on on il y a il y a plus il
y a que nous qui parlons du coup
franco-allemand. Les Allemands on n'en
parle pas. Euh et effectivement on est
parfois en
les espagnols on n'en parle pas c'est ça
?
Non les Espagnols on je veux dire on il
y a il y a quand même deux pays qu'on a
toujours regardé un peu de haut et
l'Espagne. Voilà et on pourrait jouer
aussi avec le Portugal pour faire bonne
mesure. Il y a des marges de manœuvre.
Il y a des pays qui peuvent un peu
relancer que mais vous savez en 82
c'était Claude Martinel ancien leader du
PSU qui a été nommé ambassadeur de
France à Rome. Donc on avait nommé un
politique comme ambassadeur. C'est un
type extraordinaire mais je me rappelle
de ces diatri sur le fait qu'on
regardait l'Italie comme un pays dans
lequel on vient passer des vacances mais
qu'on prend pas au sérieux sur le reste.
Voilà. Donc on on il faudrait être un
peu plus mobile et euh multiplier mais
mais aussi qu'on est euh
qu'on ait cette volonté bah de faire
bouger les lignes et pas de se dire
est-ce qu'on est dans la période médiane
dans le est-ce qu'on est le plus petit
des commun ou est-ce qu'on est ceux qui
lançons d'initiatives mais lancer
initiatives sans non plus les annoncer
sans avoir consulté personne c'est aussi
ça la difficulté Si vous une initiative
géniale mais que vous avez pas consulté
auparavant, donc il faut effectivement
consulter et cetera. Là quand même il y
a plus de consultation. Bon mais le
cador a souffert quand même bah d'une
part parce que le président compte pas
dessus
que le corps a été supprimé que les
drillons pour compte pas dessus et
pourquoi le corps a été supprimé ?
Est-ce qu'on c'était pas un repère de
dormeur ? Ah non, je vous êtes sévère.
Moi je euh
le dormeur du quai, comment il
s'appelait ce monsieur là ? Son petit
surnom c'était comme ça là. Euh j'ai un
trop de
un ministre ou quoi ?
Oui oui un ministre.
Non je me rappelle du condoret mais euh
pas euh il y avait le condorset en
autres temps, mais c'était pas celui-là.
Non, franchement le la le schéma
classique du diplomate
Jean-Marco,
hein, je trouve sévère avec lui. Il a
quand même c'est un des derniers qui a
été actif sur le dossier palestinien par
exemple euh et donc qui a essayé de
faire quelque chose qui n'a pas été
suivi par le président. Donc euh
pourquoi Macron essayé de se se
débarrasser du corps diplomatique ? Bah
parce que euh alors au départ en fait
parce que il a trouvé que le il y avait
des néoconsés Gador qui s'opposaient à
sa politique mais il y avait pas que ça.
Et je veux dire quand il dénonce l'état
profond dans son discours devant les
diplomates en 2019,
c'est pas une théorie conspirationniste
ça
pour certains. Oui, mais je veux dire
l'état profond existe partout parce
qu'il y a des traditions, il y a des
structures et que dans chaque ministère,
il y a des gens qui restent en place
alors que les ministres défilent. Oui,
évidemment. Et ça ne veut pas dire que
c'est eux, mais enfin tous les ministres
s'opposent à leur administration au
départ parce que les gens sont là et
puis après si le ministre a la volonté
et la poigne, il impose sa volonté. s'il
ne l'a pas, il se fait bouffer. Mais là,
en fait, quand il dénonce l'État profond
et les néoconservateurs, il prend pas
plus de décision et le lendemain,
le DRI prononce un discours, il rend
hommage à la papesse des
néoconservateurs Thérèse de Pêche et
lui, il a pas vu les couvenirs, mais son
dircab a écrit un discours qui vient
infirmer indirectement ce qu'a fait le
président. Mais en même temps, G, il y a
pas des conservateurs, il y a des gens
qui qui avaient d'autres opinions. Je
pense que Macron euh en fait, il il
pense qu'il est trop intelligent, qu'il
a pas besoin des autres, qu'il a pas
besoin de tout cela. Euh c'est pas le
premier à mépriser les diplomates.
SarkoZi le faisait euh quand même aussi
également. Et on se prive de talent. Les
gens sont compétents, ils bossent des
heures, ils ont vraiment c'est pas des
gens qui boivent du champagne en
distribuant des des rochers Ferrero
hein. C'est c'est ça a changé tout ça.
Les mecs, ils se bougent sur les les
trucs jamais été à la semaine des
ambassadeurs, vous ? Non.
Si si,
ça ressemble quand même à une soirée
Ferrero hein.
Non, pas du tout. Mais cette année, elle
a pas eu lieu. Elle a pas eu lieu sous
le prétexte de Jeux Olympique. Bah
voilà, c'est voulait pas avoir la GR.
Non non, c'est vraiment intéressant la
semaine des voyez tout le monde, il y a
des débats intéressants et cetera. Non,
ça a été réduit un peu par le DRI.
D'ailleurs, c'était plus intéressant
sous Fabus. Et le DRIAN, il avait plus
que quelques mois être ministre. Il
aurait pu partir par la grande porte et
beaucoup de diplomates lui en veulent
pour dire "Je refuse de sacrifier mon
corps diplomatique. Il a préféré
préserver le sien en ayant d'autres
missions par la suite de ne pas
s'opposer à la disparition du corps des
diplomates.
Comment vous jugez cette ces fameuses
lettres de diplomates contre Macron ? Si
moi je vous dis un ministre ça ferme sa
gueule ou ça obéit ou c'est quoi la
phrase consacrée ?
Un ministre ça ferme sa gueule ou ça
démissionne. Ça c'est chevinement. Un
ministre mais pas un diplomate.
D'accord. Mais un fonctionnaire ça écrit
ça écrit une lettre contre le président
ou c'est pas une écrit comme président
c'est qu'il y a une fuite organisée par
les n conservateurs. Vous avez 20 21
diplomates français en poste dans les
pays du proche orient ou administration
centrale qui qui exercent quelque part
leur devoir d'alerte. On leur reproche
de pas prendre de risque. Ils disent bon
voilà, ils disent ce qu'il voi ils
disent que ce qu'il voit c'est que le
prestige de la France par suivisme à
l'égard d'Israël notamment au
proche-rient ce prestige diminue et que
nous sommes plus populaires, que nous
avons perdu beaucoup notre popularité
dans la plupart des pays arabes même si
on sait bien que les régimes arabes se
foutent des Palestiniens qu'on dit
récemment mais on est moins populaire
dans tous ces pays-là et moi je le
constate c'est tout le monde vous le
dira. Donc ils alertent et ça fuite dans
la presse. Mais c'est ceux qui sont
opposés à leur alerte qu'il faut fuiter
pour que ça fasse pite. Mais en fait les
mecs ont fait leur boulot. Ils ont ils
disent et au lieu que ça soit machin
ambassadeur là-bas, ils font pour bien
montrer que c'est une perception
globale. Et effectivement ça a rendu
furieux le président mais les mecs ont
fait leur boulot. Ils l'ont fait avec
courage en osant s'opposer au pouvoir.
Mais c'est ça la loyauté.
Et pourquoi ils ont pas démissionné ?
Bah parce que c'est leur gagne pas,
parce que et cetera. Disons que c'est
ils à la fois parce qu'ils espèrent
limiter les dégâts que qui s'il
démissionne, ils vont laisser la place à
des mecs qui sont pires et qui vont
encore plus aggraver la situation. Non,
je pense que certains peuvent
démissionner si vraiment ceux qui
démissionnent, c'est pour partir dans le
privé parfois, on l'a vu, mais ceux qui
Mais ils vont pas eux
partir dans le privé euh chez NSO.
Euh non non non c'est non ça vous faites
référence à Gérardo qui a démissionné je
vous signale
pas quand il a appris d'ailleurs
il a non et etarou n'est pas un
néoconservateur contrairement à ce que
beaucoup de gens disent c'est un vrai
patriote euh français et et donc ils
n'ont pas démissionné parce que en fait
ils aiment aussi ce métier ils aiment ce
métier mais effectivement ils n'ont pas
été écoutés et bon il y a des débats et
là bah on va voir que je connais pas
personnellement Johan Barreau. Il a eu
une réaction digne lorsque des policiers
ont sont venus malmener
des policiers israéliens sont venus
malmener des gendarmes français
euh dans une enceinte qui est gérée par
la France. Euh
ça c'est c'est pas une ambassade hein.
Non mais c'est c'est un lieu qui est
attribué à la France depuis 150 ans et
qui est sous mandat français. Euh et
donc et que ces gendarmes ont un statut
diplomatique, mais ça a pas suscité
quand même beaucoup de protestations de
la part de beaucoup de gens. Jean-L
Barreau est la bonne. Bon, on va voir ce
qu'il va faire mais c'est vrai qu'il
part avec un handicap au départ parce
que bah ça fait longtemps que le cas est
en désérance.
À l'international, la France ça va être
réduit à quoi ?
Alors en fait, moi je dis que à la fois
on reste quand même une voix qui peut
être écoutée mais que cette voix est
moins écouté que début du siècle.
Je commence à avoir pas mal de
bouteilles. Moi au début de ce siècle,
je suis généraliste, je suis pas
spécialiste d'une région. Donc je vais
un peu au gré des invitations, des
opportunités un peu sur les cinq
continents. Vous
vous déployez comment ?
En fonction des invitations ou en
fonction de votre secteur de recherche ?
Bah en fait, c'est lié, c'est que je
suis pas invité à parler de choses que
je connais pas. Donc généralement, il y
a un colloque, je viens y faire un
speech ou une ambassade m'invite pour
faire des conférences, mais c'est
souvent quand même pour participer à des
colloques multinationaux et cetera. Bon,
euh ou au gré des ambassades, les
alliances françaises et cetera pour
faire pour faire une des conférences. Je
veux dire, au début du 21e siècle, la
France était le pays occidental le plus
populaire dans ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui le sud global qui n'avait
pas encore ce nom. On était très
différent des autres pays occidentaux et
donc le le fait d'être français était
donnait une prime. Il y avait plusieurs
facteurs. Il y avait bah l'attitude au
proche orient, le refut à la guerre
d'Irak, mettait un peu de victoire à la
coupe du monde et cetera. On était
différent. le golomitand, c'est que on
était perçu comme étant différent des
autres pays occidentaux
et donc on avait une prime de
singularité
qui s'est amenuisé au fur et à mesure et
le tournant c'est pas
à mesure c'est Sarkozi
non justement c'est Chirac
c'est Shirac 2005
qui prend peur de sa propre audace de
s'être opposé aux États-Unis et il y a
des menaces il y a les campagnes sur
l'antisémitisme en France aux États-Unis
puisque on s'oppose à Charon et cetera
et Chirac prend peur en fait il dit et
donc la priorité de vous rappelez qu'à
l'époque Condolisia Ris dit on va
oublier l'Allemagne pardonner la Russie
et punir la France
et la France a eu peur de ça et donc la
réconciliation avec les États-Unis a été
est devenue la priorité de la diplomatie
française. D'où l'invitation à Évian au
G7 des États-Unis. On était très content
qu'il vienne et donc on a un peu rebattu
et sur le proche Orient, vous avez en
plus Charon qui se retire de Gaza.
Les plus lucides disait en fait c'est
pas du tout un premier vers la paix,
c'est pour se débarrasser à l'époque
d'un 400000 d'un 400000 Palestiniens
pour remettre d'quer le tableau
démographique sur l'ensemble Israël
territoire occupé entre juifs et arabes.
Et en fait c'est pour mieux contrôler la
si Jordanie ce qu'il a fait. Mais il y
avait des gens à l'époque, il disent
"Ah, c'est génial, c'est le premier pas
vers la paix." Il accueille Charon,
grande réconciliation. Il y a son ami
Arari qui est assassiné prant par les
Syriens, donc il se fâche aussi et puis
il a son accident, son AVC qui
l'affaiblit et puis il enfin bon. Donc
déjà avec Shiraq, on a perdu un peu. Il
y a déjà eu une sorte d'étoile qui a
palu, qui a pas pardon. Sarkozy
fait campagne sur Sarcole américain,
sarco israélien et cetera. réintègre le
conseil de l'OTAN,
réintègre les organes militaires
intégrés de l'OTAN. Et en même temps,
quand je consulte enfin quand je fais
une comparaison des différents discours
des présidents français depuis Sarco
devant la conférence des ambassadeurs,
c'est Sarco qui était encore le plus
cach avec Israël en disant que Gazette
une prison à ciel ouvert, en disant que
comment que le le la non résolution du
conflit nourrissait le terrorisme.
Maintenant, vous avez plus le droit de
dire ça parce que sinon vous justifiez.
Si vous dites que la nonision du conflit
nourrit le terroriste, vous dites qu'on
justifie le 7 octobre. Voilà ce que bon.
Et ensuite bah et ensuite Hollande qui
fait campagne qui fait campagne en
disant on va reconnaître à Palestine.
Son conseil diplomatique malheureusement
disparu Paul Jean Ortiz dans son premier
discours devant les ambassadeurs en août
2012 met la reconnaissation de la
Palestine et c'est François Land qui
rille de sa main bloche cette référence.
Et donc voilà où on en est. C'est donc
il y a quand même une perte un peu et
une fois encore Macron qui a fait
campagne en 2017 sur la notion de
Golomiterandis qui est on par les
néoconservateurs
maintenant en parle moins et recherche
plutôt la cohésion occidentale au prix
au prix d'une peut-être perte
d'originalité.
en parcourant votre fiche Wikipédia qui
a dû être réécrite, réécrite et je la
regarde plus parce qu'il y a tous mes
amis là qui la nourrissent, qui la
pourrissent régulièrement. Truc
amis entre guillemets.
Ouais.
C'est quoi cette histoire de fiche du
temps que vous étiez au Parti socialiste
?
En 2001, je fais une note au PS en
disant euh je j'avais été euh j'étais
très réticent par rapport à la guerre du
Kosovo. Je trouvais que ça à l'époque.
Il y avait pas de mandat de l'ONU.
Pourtant, c'était mes copains la Richard
et Uber Vine qui étaient au
gouvernement. Mais j'avais du mal avec
ça et je voyais toutes les bonnes âmes
qui disaient "C'est notre devoir
intervenir, on peut pas laisser un
peuple et cetera."
Et donc j'ai fait une note sur le deux
poids de mesure si on est contre
l'occupation en fait en disant on peut
pas à la fois dire qu'il faut faire la
guerre auve et accepter l'occupation des
Palestiniens par Israël. Déjà à l'époque
en 2001, il y avait quelques
responsables politiques israéliens qui
étaient déjà assez sévèrement burné en
terme de propos raciste. Donc je mets ça
et et je dis on ne peut pas, il y a du
de poids de mesure, on si on défend des
principes universels, il faut les
appliquer de façon universelle et pas
sélective.
Et comme à l'époque on me disait souvent
"Oui, mais on peut pas, tu comprends le
vote juif Je dis mais on doit défendre
des principes universels. De toute
façon, même sur le plan des principes
euh bah comme il y a euh plus enfin pour
si c'est uniquement pour les raisons
électorales, ça tient pas non plus parce
que les musulmans sont plus nombreux que
les juifs. Alors c'est vrai mais ensuite
je suis cour parce qu'ils sont pas
organisés, ils votent pas pour ça et
cetera. Bon et donc bien sûr alors que
je parlais de principes universel et que
je disais en quoi l'occupation
je l'occupation d'un peuple par un
autre, elle est plus admissible au 21e
siècle. Elle était déjà plus au 20e.
Mais bien sûr, les gens ont dit "Ah, il
dragu arabes. C'est l'homme qui dit que
comme il y a plus d'arabes que de juifs,
il faut être pro palestinien." Non, je
disais qu'il fallait être pour
l'indépendance de la Palestine parce que
c'est le droit international, parce que
c'est le droit du peuple à disposer même
mais adversaires ont trouvé plus facile.
Vous savez quand le sage montre la lune,
l'imbécile regarde le doigt. Et donc ils
ont dit non c'est ils ont transformé ça
en disant c'est celui qui a dit qu'il y
a plus d'arabes que de juifs c'est et ça
court toujours. Je crois que on me dit
que F grotte a quoi répéter il sait que
c'est faux fil grotte mais en fait ces
gens se foutent de de la vérité ils se
foutent des faits ils prennent des faits
alternatives. Donc ils vous font dire
des trucs que vous n'avez jamais dit
pour s'en offusquer et pour masquer le
vrai problème. Le vrai problème, c'est
que est-ce que en 2024, il est normal
qu'un peuple n'ait pas le droit à
l'autodétermination et que cel ceci lui
soit refusé par la force ?
Vous parliez de Wikipédia et de vos
amoureux de Wikipédia ou vos haters
comme on dit chez les Jones. Est-ce que
vous avez pas l'impression que sur
Wikipédia, il y a des groupes
spécialisés pour ruiner la réputation ?
Et
ou non, mais c'est très mal géré. Je
vous faites des démentis. Moi j'ai
envoyé des trucs factuels pour dire j'ai
fait euh ouvert tel bouquin enfin j'ai
publié tel même ça il le ils le mettent
pas. Donc je sais pas qui contrôle ça
mais je veux dire à la fois des fois si
vous devez vérifier la surface d'un pays
ça peut être utile mais sur les
biographi
c'est géré j'essaie de voir et c'est
plus qu'opaque. C'est plus qu'opaque. Et
en tous les cas euh c'est effectivement
le comment calomnity
question internet. On va en prendre une
une courte.
C'est pas une question ça.
Conflits russaux Ukraine, quels sont les
scénarios d'évolution dans les 5
prochains dans les 5 prochains mois ?
Dans les 5 prochains mois, cesser le
feu, non accord de paix, ce qu'on
appelle un scénario coréen. Sauf que là,
la Russie va garder ses gains
territoriaux alors que la Corée du Nord
n'a pas eu de gains territoriaux après
la guerre qu'elle a lancé en 1950.
Et tu as acheté ton téléphone en Chine
toi ? Non. Non. parce que on a envoyé
des gens en Chine. Euh question internet
que Netaniaou limoge le ministre de la
défense Joaf Galon.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire pour vous ?
Bah ça veut dire que Yo Galan, qui n'est
pas une colombe avait dit que les buts
de guerre étaient atteints à Gaza
puisque le Hamas n'existe pratiquement
plus et qu'il est temps d'arrêter la
guerre. Et dit ben non parce que si
j'arrête la guerre c'est donc un cesser
le feu. Si je fais un cesser le feu, Ben
Virismotric se retire de la coalition et
je tombe et du coup les juges vont venir
roder dans mes affaires plus me poser
des questions sur la façon dont je n'ai
pas évité le 7 octobre. Donc la
poursuite de la guerre et la poursuite
de
au pouvoir, lui il attend, il attendait
le 9 octobre, plein de gens disaient il
va pas rester au pouvoir. Il dit "Mais
j'attends si Trump est réuge et et
cetera et donc son objectif c'est
d'attendre les prochaines élections, pas
de convoquer des nouvelles élections si
son gouvernement tombe." Et il peut s'il
Mais pour ça, il dépend de Vengar et
Smotrich dont on connaît le programme,
c'est notamment qu'ils veulent annoncer
l'annexion officielle de la S Jordanie.
Question internet. Pourrait-on dire que
les guerres d'influence sur nos pays ne
sont pas plus des monopoles d'État
étranger, mais inclus aujourd'hui des
grandes entreprises d'investissement et
de la finance ? Cela ne complique-t-il
pas les analyses géopolitiques ?
Alors, tu peux vous pouvez répéter ?
Pourrait-on dire que les guerres
d'influence sur nos pays ne sont plus
des monopoles d'État étrangers mais
inclus aujourd'hui des grandes
entreprises d'investissement et de la
finance ? Bien sûr, mais c'est pas
nouveau, ça se développe mais que des
grands groupes industriels et voulu
faire de l'influence, acheter l'opinion
et cetera, c'est pas nouveau. Bon, enfin
Coca-Cola a commencé comme ça depuis le
départ. Donc en fait, vous avez
effectivement tout cela pour vendre
quelque chose qui ne correspond pas
toujours à la réalité.
Revenons sur la Chine.
Qu'est-ce que la Chine Qu'est-ce que la
Chine veut ? Qu'est-ce que la Chine va
pouvoir faire ? Comment la Chine réagit
par rapport à la sécurisation par les
États-Unis du collier de perles depuis
un certain nombre de décennies ?
Comment elle se sent ? Elle a développé
la route de la soie parce que elle veut
un chemin bis si les États-Unis ferment
le collier de perle. Comment ça se passe
?
Alors ce que veut la Chine
officiellement, c'est
offrir le bonheur à tous les Chinois et
reprendre sa place. Mais en fait, ça
veut dire sans être dit officiellement
devenir la première puissance mondiale.
Et à la place de qui ? À la place des
États-Unis évidemment parce que c'est
eux qui occupe le poste pour l'instant.
Et donc c'est leur objectif et ils vont
y parvenir très probablement. On va voir
sauf si Trump relance merveilleusement
la machine économique américaine en
écrasant les autres. Mais les Chinois
ont une vision à long terme. Ils sont
plutôt cohérents là-dessus. Alors,
Dijinping a une crispation autoritaire
parce que sa grande crainte, c'est le
démantellement du pays. Et en fait, son
obsession c'est maintenant que les
Chinois sont devenus riches, ils
obéissent moins, ils pourraient devenir
un petit peu égoïste, moins pensé à
l'État et cetera. Donc bon effectivement
il y a bon mais en même temps je le on a
bien vu le Covid la le zéro Covid c'est
une politique stupide et en même temps
quand les Chinois en ont eu vraiment
marre ils ont tapé sur les casseroles et
les ginb ont bien été obligé d'accepter
la fin du Covid en fait donc c'est un
régime autoritaire mais ce qu'on ne voit
pas toujours dans les dénonciations de
ce régime bien sûr c'est un régime
autoritaire bien sûr il y a un gros
problème avec lesour bien sûr il y a un
gros problème avec hong kong tout ça et
vrai mais les chinois
taïwan aussi un peu
et taïwan oui bien sûr
Mais les Chinois pour l'instant Taiïwan
finalement on survit hein et indépendant
de fait mais les Chinois de Pékin,
Shanghai ou Cranton, ils sont contents
d'être chinois.
Euh bon donc parce que ça marche pour
l'instant. Si ça marchait plus, il râai
mais pour l'instant ça marche. Ils
peuvent consommer et cetera et bah il
préfèrent l'ordre à la liberté.
Il y a pas une demande excessive pour le
moment. Il y a une demande de démocratie
de la part quelques intellectuels mais
pas de la part de la population.
Peut-être que ça viendra dans une ou
deux générations mais c'est pas
l'urgence pour l'instant. Pour l'instant
ce qu'ils veulent c'est consommer quoi
parce que leurs grands-parents mourrait
de faim.
La récession est-elle inévitable au vu
recul démographique en Chine ? Non, pas
forcément parce que l'intelligence
artificielle peut palier à tout cela
que par définition, il pouvait pas avoir
une croissance à 10 % 12 % pendant très
longtemps, qui a eu un ralentissement,
qui a l'abus spéculative immobilière,
qui a un chômage des jeunes, tout ça
pose problème. Mais euh le le
ralentissement démographique, alors
c'est vrai que auparavant tu avais qu'un
enfant, maintenant il pouvait en avoir
deux, vous pouvez en avoir trois, c'est
le même problème au Japon. C'est encore
pire en Corée du Sud. C'est un problème
et ça tant que dans ces pays il sera le
avoir un enfant c'est 30 % du budget.
Donc c'est des choix économiques. Alors
ce qui est un peu curieux c'est que
comme il peut avoir l'enfant ils ont des
animaux domestiques qui leur coûtent
aussi une fortune. Donc je suis pas sûr
ça soit très pertinent sur le long terme
mais il se réfugie là-dessus. Mais donc
tant qu'il aura une concurrence
effrainée pour les places dans l'école
et cetera, tant que le fait d'avoir des
enfants sera aussi cher et tant que
aussi euh les hommes vont considérer que
bah c'est aux femmes de faire tout ça et
que c'est encore des sociétés très
machistes. Mais une fois encore la
dénatétalité, elle est encore pire en
Corée du Sud. Pourtant, c'est le pays de
la Capop, c'est le pays euh et cetera et
aussi au Japon et donc en Chine. Mais le
fait que l'Inde dépasse en nombre
d'habitants la Chine, ça leur sert pas
forcément superbement en terme de
réussite économique, même s'il y a une
bonne croissance en Inde pour l'instant,
l'Inde a une très forte croissance mais
ils sont quand même très très loin
derrière. Le pays indien c'est un 20e un
5e, pardon, 20 % du PIB chinois.
Question internet.
Bonsoir et merci pour la pertinence de
l'échange. C'est juste une question.
Peut-être un ami à moi qui a écrit ça.
Pas c'est peut-être votre femme. Non.
Ouais. Ouais. Je pas. Merci. Merci
de
je te remercie mon épouse.
Est-ce qu'il y a encore des pays qui se
soucient de la voix de la France à
l'international ?
Oui, mais moins qu'avant. Et ils sont
moins nombreux qu'avant. Effectivement
quand même disons qu'il faut éviter de
passer d'un extrême à l'autre de passer
où le monde entier arrête de respirer
pour savoir ce que pense le président de
la République française à il peut faire
n'importe quoi. Plus personne n'a rien à
battre. La France est encore légitime à
s'exprimer sur un certain nombre de
sujets et en fait sur à peu près on est
légitime à s'exprimer sur les
changements climatiques, on est légitime
à s'exprimer sur la dette. On est
légitime à s'exprimer sur les questions
numériques, de réglementation et cetera.
On est encore légitime, on l'est moins
qu'avant. On est moins qu'avant mais on
l' encore donc bon et donc un sursaut
est possible. C'est ça aussi qu'il faut
voir parce que si on dit bah ça y est
foutu et ben on ferme boutique et on se
raccroche au wagon américain on fait
plus rien.
Question internet
on va prendre celle-ci.
Comment percevez-vous les tensions
sociales en France ?
Ah bah elles vont, on voit qu'elles
s'aggra, on voit que c'est pas facile,
qu'on annonce des charrettes quand même.
Bon, Michelin Auchamp et d'autres
s'annoncent et puis
c'était prévisible.
Oui, oui, oui. J'imagine, enfin, j'ai
pas les éléments mais j'imagine que
c'est pas venu de out of the blue, bien
sûr. Voilà.
Quand l'énergie coûte plus cher,
souffrent. Bon et puis le enfin les le
prix du logement dans et cetera, enfin
tout ça. le la l'inflation et cetera et
puis enfin je veux dire c'est vrai que
pour beaucoup le prix du logement obère
aussi complètement
les capacités
notamment des des jeunes ménages et des
jeunes et cetera
à faire des enfants
à faire des enfants et enfin je veux
dire pour quel pour un célibataire vivre
à Paris est extrêmement compliqué du
fait du coup du logement et cetera donc
il y a vraiment des des vrais problèmes
sociaux il y a vraiment de la misère
vous voyez bien comme moi le nombre de
sans-abris qui augmente régulièrement.
Régulièrement qui augmente.
Pourtant Macron avait dit plus un seul
sans-abri.
Ouais. Je sais pas si c'est lui qui
l'avait dit ou un autre. Je crois que
c'est un précédent président. Et puis
euh et puis aussi tout simplement les
gens qui n'arrivent pas enfin je ça
quand même le le les les les gens de
plus en plus nombreux qui vont au
secours populaire qui vont au
banquimentaires.
Les étudiants
les étudiants aussi
qui font la queue.
Bon voilà donc c'est quand même pas
terrible quoi.
Ça nous mène ça nous mène à des révoltes
et des tensions genre guerre civile.
Guerre civile non mais je veux dire les
gens sont tendus. Vous le voyez bien les
gens sont tendus parce qu'ils sont pas
heureux. Vous avez quand même un climat
internal qui est quand même partivement
pourri.
C'est pour ça que les géopolitologues
sont dépressifs en ce moment.
Bah franchement, il y a pas vraiment de
raison de se de raison de se réjouir
honnêtement hein. Quand je vois
l'accumulation, moi je dire ce qui se
passe là au Prochrient, je vois pas
comment ça va s'arranger et je vois pas
Est-ce que l'Occident est venu mourir à
Gaza ? Bah le crédit moral de l'Occident
en tous les cas le crédit moral je on
aura du mal à aller faire la leçon sur
les valeurs universelles aux autres avec
ça. On a perdu une partie de notre une
partie notre crédit de stratégique en
Ukraine et une partie de notre activité
morale à Gaza parce que effectivement il
y a quand même je veux dire alors est-ce
qu'il y a génocide ou pas ? la justice
tranchera et l'histoire tranchera. Mais
en tous les cas, il y a une situation
génocidaire, ça on peut s'attendre. Et
la convention de 1948 sur le génocide,
c'est pas seulement une convention
d'interdiction, c'est une convention de
prévention.
Donc s'il y a un risque, on doit
l'empêcher.
Bon, donc là, on va voir l'offensive sur
le nord de Gaza et cetera. Non,
franchement, je
Oui, je veux dire, mon métier me
déprime. Mon métier me déprime.
Heureusement que j'ai des amis, une
famille et cetera et que j'ai d'autres
motifs personnels de satisfaction, mais
mon métier me déprime.
Et
c'est quoi ? Comment vous faites pour ne
moins moins déprimer ? Bah déjà des B je
alors déjà déjà parce que j'ai des amis,
une famille et c'est des bonheurs ça
pose des questions.
Oui.
Ils sont conscients de votre dépression.
Comment
alors pas je dis pas dépression mais ils
sont conscients que ça commence à peser
sur le si boulot.
Bah il voit bien quand même que
effectivement c'est que c'est pas gay et
cetera. Heureusement aussi j'ai une
formidable équipe àis. Il y a dans ce
malheur une très bonne équipe de gens
qui sont soudés, qui savent rigoler et
cetera et du coup effectivement le matin
quand j'ime la radio, je déprime, quand
j'arrive à les ris, je rigole un peu
plus et il y a une bonne ambiance et ça
permet un peu de tenir. Mais
l'actualité, elle est elle est pas rose
quand même quoi. Elle est pas rose. Mais
effectivement, je fais des choses qui
m'intéressent dont d'ailleurs ma BD dont
vous avez dit que vous parliez, vous
n'avez pas encore parlé.
Bah qui vous a dit que c'était terminé
là ?
Ah bon ? D'accord.
On se détend hein.
Ouais.
Un petit conseil si vous voulez avoir le
moral,
un petit discours d'Emmanuel Macron
avec en fond sonore la la bande
originale de Manon des sources
tout de suite c'est c'est c'est
transcendantal.
Ouais. La musique suffit pas.
Non.
Vous avez d'autres géopolitologues qui
viennent vous parler de ça que ça
commence à taper sur aussi boulot
queouais ouais. encore, je déjeun avec
une collègue là aujourd'hui. Voilà, ça
ça commence. Il y a aussi un peu l'état
de la France qui nous rend pas très
joyeux et effectivement quand on observe
l'élection de Trump n'a pas donné le
moral à beaucoup de gens parce qu'on
voit que c'est quand même lourd de
menaces sur certaines choses. Une fois
encore les guerres et cetera et puis on
pourrait parler de la RDC, du Soudan et
cetera. Enfin, il y a pas beaucoup de
bonnes nouvelles.
On parle pas aussi de de des millions de
morts qui sont passés très récemment en
Afrique, hein.
Oui, moi j'en parle. J'avais d'ailleurs
invité Mukoi dans un de mes podcasts.
J'en parle régulièrement. Euh mais en
même temps, je refuse ceux qui vous
disent, les cin qui vous disent "Ah oui,
mais vous parlez de Gaza parce que vous
êtes antisémite et vous parlez pas du
Soudan."
Euh c'est les mêmes qui se servent qui
n'ont jamais parlé du Soudan et qui tout
d'un coup de façon très cynique se
servent du Soudan pour dire bah voilà il
faut parler du Soudan pour ne pas parler
des gens de Gaza. Il faut parler de tous
les morts. Faut parler de tous les
morts. La différence aussi c'est que
je dire le général et Méti d'ailleurs un
des néoconservateurs a fait la promotion
d'ampérale francel pour pas le nommer.
C'est quand même la promotion générale
des méti quand même le faire. Mais il y
a un pére comme expert après. Et donc le
le aussi c'est que la différence entre
les morts du Soudan et les morts de
Gaza, c'est que les généraux soudanais
disent pas qu'ils appartiennent au monde
occidental. Ils disent pas et on va pas
les soutenir, on leur voit pas d'armes.
On a fait un embargo sur eux. Donc aussi
quand quand on met sur le même pied le
Soudan et Gaza pour dire non euh il faut
parler des deux en même temps. Non,
c'est pas la même chose parce qu'il y a
un pays qui se réclame de son
appartenance au mon occidentale et c'est
parce qu'il se définit comme occidental
qu'on est allié avec lui et que donc
c'est parce qu'on est allié avec lui que
l'on récupère partiellement une charge
morale par rapport à cela aux yeux des
autres pays, aux yeux des pays du sud.
Et c'est pour cela que notre crédit
moral est atteint parce que le général
méti où
les mouvements du M du du M23 en RDC,
ils sont pas du monde occidental et on n
pas on n pas alors on peut nous
incriminer pour notre inaction mais pas
pour un soutien.
Question internet, j'attrape la
première. Est-ce que Sky a parlé de la
couverture médiatique de nos gendarmes
en Israël ?
On a parlé un peu.
On a parlé un petit peu. Ouais. Ouais.
Ouais. On
continuer d'en parler. Bah on en a
parlé. Si si on en a parlé. Alors la
couverture médiatique,
elle a existé un peu quand même. Il y a
bah par exemple le général Richou sur un
plateau a dit c'est un état voyou où son
honneur de militaire a été mis en cause
quand même. Enfin il a ressenti ça. Si
la couverture médiatique a été a été
correcte. Par contre il y a eu moins de
protestation de la part dans les
politiques que dans d'autres cas.
Imaginez que ça se passe en Iran
ou en Chine,
aux États-Unis.
Voilà. Donc bon là il y a toujours,
c'est vrai que l'accusation
d'antisémitisme dès qu'on critique
Netaniaou a réussi quelque chose dans le
débat publicque, l'assimilation
antisémitisme, antisionisme et critique
du gouvernement ou de l'action du
gouvernement israélien qui sont trois
choses différentes et qui sont mêlées
puisque il y a très vite et beaucoup de
gens se testent parce qu'ils ont pas
envie de se prendre une sheit storm en
étant traité d'antisémite. Il y a dans
mon métier, je connais plein de gens qui
me disent "Je pense comme toi, mais je
le dirai pas en public." Ils se
planquent parce qu'ils ont pas envie de
se prendre les sembl que je me suis
pris. Et et donc effectivement, il y a
quand même aussi la peur de dire "On va
quand même y aller,
on va s'en prendre plein la gueule." Je
dire l'antisémitisme c'est la haine des
juifs. L'antisioniste, c'est
l'opposition à la existence de l'État
d'Israël pour les juifs que certains il
y a des antisionistes qui sont juifs par
ailleurs, soit très religieux, soit très
à gauche. Et la critique du gouvernement
israélien, c'est dire je suis pas
d'accord quand on va voir des civils. De
même que je suis pas d'accord quand
Poutine bombarde des civils en Ukraine.
Ces trois choses différentes, on les
réunit sur le même plan. Euh ce qui à
terme je pense peut vraiment être
dangereux. Dangereux.
Question internet. Les Espagnols ont-il
eu raison de sortir du marché européen
de l'énergie ? Alors, j'ai j'ai je suis
pas assez économiste pour répondre, mais
je pense que s'ils l'ont fait, c'est
bon si euh il je veux dire le je trouve
que le le gouvernement espagnol agit de
façon assez habile dans la défense de
ses intérêts et c'est mettre les pieds
dans le plat lorsqu'il le faut et ça
leur récit plutôt bien.
Alors là, je vais découvrir la question
avec vous. Dans l'une de vos
présentations, il a traité Bolsonaro de
Trump en tongue. Qu'on aime Bolsonaro ou
non, là n'est pas la question. Ce
commentaire révèle simplement le
complexe de supériorité de cet individu.
C'est comme si je disais que Macron est
un Frenchy mangeur de cuisse de
grenouille.
Alors attendez la source parce que je me
rappelle pas avoir dit ça.
Ah bah là je je la découvre avec vous
donc
Oui. Non mais il peut sourcer ce
monsieur qui dit ça.
Oui. Alors Amine il s'appelle On lui
demande sa source tout de suite.
Ouais. Euh
euh
question bonsoir. Une question me
tracasse. Pourquoi s'obstiner à rester
en Europe alors même que la France n'a
plus ou presque plus son mot à dire sur
les différents sujets ? Pourquoi sortir
semble-t-il si bête ?
Bah, je pense honnêtement que un Frexite
nous affaiblirait. On serait encore plus
à poil sans l'euro et cetera. Donc
l'idée c'est pas de sortir de l'Europe,
c'est de d'essayer de mieux faire valoir
nos intérêts au sein de l'Union
européenne et euh bon de nommer des
commissaires compétents peut-être de
faire valoir notre point de vue, d'être
plus vindicatif au sein de l'Union
européenne mais je pense qu'on
souffrirait si on sortait regarder les
britanniques. Le Brexit leur a pas
réussi, ils vont pas mieux depuis le
Brexit. Donc ça serait pareil voir pire
pour nous.
Question internet qu'on découvre en même
temps. Tout à l'heure, Pascal Bonifas
parlait de coup manquer vis-à-vis du
Brésil. La France devrait-elle orienter
ses alliances diplomatiques sur le
terrain latino-américain pour
l'interrogation.
Comment voit-il le futur des relations
diplomatiques avec le continent africain
?
Alors avec le continent latinoaméricain,
le problème c'est qu'on en fait un peu
trop avec Miley et pas assez avec Loula
et donc là c'est pas très bien. Mais on
a des partenaires. Il y a aussi le
Mexique avec une présidente quand même
qui a beaucoup de d'alans et qui change
son pays. Il y a aussi un partenaire en
Colombie. On a des partenaires
potentiels en Amérique latine bien sûr.
Et quant au continent africain, bah
c'est pareil là vous dites parler de
lanceur d'alerte. Moi ma charche la
charcheuse Afrique de de l'IRIS Russie
avait dit un an avant le coup d'état au
Niger il y a des risques de coup d'état
et parce que le terrain et on disait oui
mais enfin bon voilà peu vous connaissez
rien et tout le l'alerte sur la fatigue
de la France en Afrique occidentale et
beaucoup de gens de terrain l'ont dit
ils n'ont pas été écoutés donc là il
faut qu'on reprenne tout parce que la
politique sécuritaire la politique un
peu de tout militariser dans les
relations nous a beaucoup coûté, mais il
y a peut-être d'autres choses à faire
avec l'Afriqueusophone, avec l'Afrique
anglophone dans lequel avec lesquels il
y a pas ce passif historique que l'on a
bon le l'Afrique francophone.
Je trouve qu'on a réagi de façon plus
intelligente avec le nouveau pouvoir au
Sénégal qu'avec les nouveaux pouvoirs
ailleurs parce que on n pas dit ah non
c'est pas celui qu'on voulait et cetera.
On a accepté même si au départ il a un
discours un peu antifrançais mais on a
bien amorcé la vague et il y a peut-être
encore des choses à faire. Mais
effectivement dire au Niger on bougera
pas alors on est obligé de bouger faut
enfin on a parfois manqué de réalisme
par
bah par un peu lubris quoi hein.
Trois questions. Pourquoi la Chine
vend-elle les parts du bon du trésor
américain qu'elle détient au profit de
l'or ? Deè question on parle de la
République démocratique du Congo,
d'Haïti du Liban. 3e question, la
réflexion, une une réflexion sur le
Bitcoin à 82000 dollars euh euros,
pardon, ça peut changer des choses en
terme d'économie future ou rien du tout.
Faux débat interrogation.
Alors, la Chine vend des dollars, des
bons du trésor parce qu'elle veut s'en
débarrasser au fur et à mesure pour ne
pas se retrouver prisonnière, mais pas
massivement parce qu'elle se ruinerait
elle-même et qu'elle pense que l'or va
monter, ce qui je crois se confirme.
RDC, on en a parlé, je sais pas quelle
est la question. Liban, Haïti, Haïti.
C'est vraiment l'exemple
dramatique d'un pays que depuis le
départ d'Aristide va de mal en pis
Haïti qui était beaucoup plus riche que
la République dominicaine au début des
années 60 et qui maintenant un pays qui
est livré au gang, qui est vraiment sur
lequel il y a plus rien et on voit pas
le Kenya envoyer des policiers mais ça
suffit pas, on voit pas disons que c'est
miné de l'intérieur et l'intervention
internationale ne suffit pas à restaurer
un ordre et c'est vraiment un pays qui
s'enfonce sous nos yeux qui va ça va
devenir ganglang quoi. C'est vraiment
très dommage. Quand le troisème c'était
le Liban.
Oui.
Ouais. Et ben le Liban et effectivement
je veux dire qui qu'elle est déjà mal en
point que la guerre israélienne vient
encore plus affaiblir. Il y a quand même
1200000 réfugiés. Donc ça serait 12
millions en France à peu près si on
faisait.
Donc ss réfugiés longtemps, comment ils
vont faire pour travailler, s'éduquer,
pour produire, pour bouffer tout ça ?
C'est compliqué. Quand à l' RDC, c'est
un pays qui a bon tout le monde connaît
cette phrase, le scandale géologique. Un
pays qui a été ruiné par ses dirigeants,
on a accepté au nom de la lutte de
contreisme au Boutou puis Kabila et
cetera. On a trop longtemps laissé quand
même le Rwanda le piller parce que le
Rwanda exporte des choses qu'il ne
produit pas. Chisekedi semble vouloir
reprendre un peu Chisekedi qui était en
fait le choix quand quand il était lieu
première fois. Il y avait Fayulun enfin
un candidat qui avait rangisé l'élection
Kabila qui avait vraiment faire perdu
qui pouvait pas être élu. On s'est dit
on va prendre celui-là on va le
contrôler. Il semble commencer à devenir
indépendant mais la RDC même malgré son
poids n'a pas les moyens de lutter
contre le Rwanda de faire respecter son
intégrité territoriale par rapport au
M23 dont tout le monde sait qu'il est
géré. aidé en sous-main par le Rwanda.
Combien de temps ça durera ? Les
Congolais détestent de ce fait les
Rwandais. Il trouvent que la France
maintient trop la part égale entre les
deux et que Tisikedi n'a pas resté
jusqu'au bout au sommet de la
francophonie parce qu'il estime qu'on
est pas en plus c'est une randaise qui
dirige l'OIF et cetera. Bon alors on
nous serine sur le fait que c'est le
pays francophone le plus important en
terme de population. Mais oui si on part
du principe que tous les Congolais
parlent français, ce qui est pas le cas.
ce qui est pas le cas, mais il y a un
potentiel énorme et on s'en occupe pas
suffisamment, ça c'est clair. Il y a
vraiment un potentiel énorme en RDC.
Question internet, bonsoir. Avec le
retour de Trump au pouvoir, quel avenir
pour l'Iran ?
Alors euh la question le la seule truc
que euh Net que Biden pardon a obtenu de
Netaniaahou, c'est qu'il ne bombarde pas
massivement l'Iran, notamment les
usines, les installations nucléaires qui
sont très profondément enfouies,
du termino pétroli non plus
et installion pétrolière. Bon, il a rien
obtenu d'autre hein. Le cesser le feu,
pas attaquer Rafa, pas bombarder Beout,
pas et cetera, il n'a rien obtenu sauf
la protection des install pétrolières.
Ce qui veut dire que quand on veut, on
peut. C'estàd que s'il avait été un peu
plus ferme avec Nou sur les autres
points, peut-être qu'il aurait pu
obtenir quelque chose. Il ne l'a pas
fait. Pourquoi il a demandé ça ? Parce
qu'il voulait pas qu'il y a un baril à
150 dollars et que si on va parler de
l'Iran et que l'Iran en face de même ou
que les outils en face d'eux- même sur
les Saoudiens, vous pouvez dire adieu à
l'économie mondiale,
à la réindustrialisation de la France.
Voilà, entre autres. Et pas seulement.
Et pas seulement. Donc qu'est-ce qui va
se passer là ? seule chose que Biden a
obtenu et si Israël a voulu Israël
demande depuis 2004 de taper l'Iran,
vous avez des gens qui depuis 2005 vous
disent que l'Iran est à 6 mois de l'arme
nucléaire. Vous avez des gens qui depuis
2005 vous disent que l'Iran est à 6 mois
d'armes nucléaire. Ça va peut-être
arriver un jour. Enfin, en tous les cas,
au départ là, c'est pas une erreur hein
quand on dit ça, c'est qu'on veut
tromper les gens. C'est pas une erreur
de dire ça. Attends,
redites-moi ce que vous venez de dire
là. Ceux qui depuis 2005 disent que
l'Iran est à 6 mois de l'arme nucléaire.
Euh,
ils sont déjà nucléis les les
je pense qu'ils ont pas encore l'arme.
Mais là, ils peê
Est-ce que tu peux penser ça ?
Parce que je bah s'il l'avait, il
l'annoncerait pour qu'on vienne pas les
emmerder.
Le c'était un tremblement de terre la
dernière fois ou c'était un essai
nucléaire en Iran ?
Ça aurait été un essu nucléaire. Je
pense que ça aurait été euh ça aurait
été vérifié enfin ça aurait été détecté
les secousses sismiques et je pense
qu'il y a une différence quand même
entre un ess nucléaire souterrain et euh
introl de terre. Non, je pense mais bon
là il doit se dire faut y aller. Enfin
pour revenir à la question à votre
question,
est-ce que Netaniaou est-ce que pardon
est-ce que Trump va dire vas-y bon alors
ça serait une fois qu'il est élu parce
qu'il faut quand même une aide technique
des États-Unis pour aller frapper un peu
tout ça. Ils peuvent pas les Israéliens
peuvent pas avec garantie le faire tout
seul. Depuis 2004, les Américains
refusent cette aide technique. Ils ont
et même une fois c'était Charon qui
avait téléphoné à Bouche qui était en
campagne électorale pour sa rélection en
2004 et il lui a il dit non pas
question. Bon bref. Alors la différence
entre Trump 1 et Trump 2 par rapport à
l'Iran, c'est que l'Iran est moins
éloigné de l'Arabie Saoudite
que entre pour le premier mandat de
Trump. Il y a une réconciliation sous
l'égis entre les Saoudiens et les
Iraniens. Et vient d'avoir un sommet
Ariade conjoint de la Ligue des
États-Urabes et de la conférence
l'organisation de la conférence
islamique dans lequel les Saoudiens ont
dit publiquement, MBS a dit publiquement
que il y aurait pas de contact à Israël
tant qu'il y aurait pas l'État
palestinien et surtout qu'il fallait ne
pas agresser l'Iran.
et MBS a quand même donné 2 milliards au
fond d'investissement de Jarette
Kouchner, le gendre de de Trump. Donc ça
compte et ben en fait Trump c'est vous
avez Israël et Arabie Saudite qui sont
qui sont en liaison non officielle parce
que on peut pas le dire mais enfin ils
se montrent pas en public ensemble, ils
couchent ensemble quand même parce
qu'ils ont tous les deux un ennemi un
ennemi qui est l'Iran, ennemi
existentiel. L'Iran n'est plus un ennemi
existentiel pour l'Arabie Saoudite et
par contre la politique israël met en
danger la politique saoudienne. Donc
est-ce que Trump prendra le risque de
laisser Taniaou frapper massivement
l'Iran ? Et lui aimerait parce qu'il
déteste l'Iran, il s'est retiré de
l'accord et cetera. Je pense que lui, il
va plutôt jouer encore durcir les
sanctions pour faire tomber le régime,
ce qui n'a pas marché mais il continue
comme ça. Les changements de régime par
la force, on sait ce que ça a donné dans
le passé, ça a pas été un franc succès
et donc j'ai pas la réponse à cette
question s'il va autoriser Israël à
frapper ou c'està-dire non parce que ça
serait un remède pire que le mal.
Comment analysez-vous la reconfiguration
des alliances au Moyen-Orient, notamment
avec les accords d'Abraham ?
Bah, en fait, chacun est venu rechercher
euh quelque chose qui l'intéressait. Les
Émirats arabes unis détestent l'Iran.
Euh, il détestent le Hamas aussi. Ils
pensent que Israël peut leur apporter
des trucs technologiques, financiers
aussi parce que maintenant, il y a un
tourisme à Dubaï, des Israéliens qui
sentent plus en sécurité à Dubaï que
dans de nombreux autres pays où c'est un
pays où il y a du soleil et cetera. Donc
a des forts croisements pour le Maroc.
C'est le Sara qui est la question
centrale. Donc je fais la paix avec
Israël parce que je suis pas en guerre
et surtout parce que du coup non
seulement Israël mais les États-Unis
reconnaissent sa souveraineté sur le
Sara. Et le Soudan, c'était la condition
pour que à l'époque il y avait pas
encore le début de la guerre civile
entre les deux généraux félons. C'était
pour que le Soudan soit retiré de la
liste des États qui sousent terroristes
manque chacun. Et c'était effectivement
la poigne de Trump. Vous voulez ça bah
de reconnaisser Israël et vous l'aurez.
Reconnaissons, c'est une réalité que
aucun de ces pays n'a mis fin à ces
relations diplomatiques avec Israël
depuis le début de la guerre et des
bombardements. Ils ont réduit la voilure
parce que bon voilà, on peut plus trop
se montrer en public. Ils ont réduit la
voilure, ils ont pas fait de choses
nouvelles mais aucun mais d'ailleurs ni
l'Égypte ni la Jordanie n'ont arrêté
leur relation diplomatique à Israël non
plus. Donc il y aura pas pour l'instant
connaissance. C'est venu freiner les
Saoudiens. C'est pas venu euh arrê
disons que c'est venu casser un
mouvement mais ça n'a pas mis fin à ce
qui était déjà acquis.
Question internet que je résume
trivialement. C'est quoi la fondation
France-Amérique ? Est-ce que vous
connaissez ? Oui, bien sûr.
C'est une fondation qui est faite pour
euh pour euh financer des activités,
pour rapprocher les élites françaises et
américaines. Donc vous avez ça dans
c'est la diplomatie d'influence, c'est
pour alors donc des gens, il y a un truc
euh qui euh marche bien, c'est les young
leaders dont j'étais moi-même d'ailleurs
en 85 de mémoire.
Voilà, vous êtes on vous offre un mois
de séjour aux États-Unis, tout frais
payer avec un perdem, vous pouvez faire
ce que vous voulez, vous demandez des
compta, vous faites un peu de tourisme,
c'est formidable et cetera. Ouais,
ça a diminué parce qu'il y a moins de
pogon maintenant mais moi quand je suis
allé, c'était un mois, j'avais un
accompagnateur,
tout vraiment tout ferait payé, c'est
bon, c'est somptueux, ça coûte du blé
quoi. Bon et c'est un programme qui est
bien fait parce que vous voyez aussi des
opposants. C'est pas du bourrage de
crâne. C'est caméra dans votre chambre.
Bah et s'il y en avait, j'ai pas vu les
films après donc je peux pas vous dire
mais j'ai pas eu le sentiment en tous
les cas. Bon il y a pas eu de compromate
sur moi pour le moment. Peut-être qu'il
y en aura. Je sais pas
c'est quoi un compromate hein ? Bah,
c'est faire chanter quelqu'un sur ses
attités sexuelles répréhensibles.
Quest question.
ce que l'on pense enfin ce que certains
disent que les les Russes ont su enfin
c'est la technique Donald Trump c'est la
technique habituelle des soviétiques
vous avez un ambassadeur qui à l'époque
où ça se faisait pas trop a été surpris
dans les bras d'une soviétique. Donc
scandale scandale la famille et de Gaul
le reçoit en disant alors monsieur
l'ambassadeur on couche donc oui on fait
chanter et cetera l'époque non
la situation en Afghanistan les talibans
le nouveau de nouveau pouvoir c'est une
be c'est de bonne augure
alors 2000 milliards dépensés en 20 ans
par les États-Unis en Afghanistan
combien de morts
alors du côté afghan on n pas le nombre
du côté américain plusieurs centaines
effectivement et des plusieurs dizaines
de milliers du côté afghan des morts
aussi du fait des talibans. Bon euh 2000
milliards pour un pays dont le PIB est
de 20 milliards par an.
Donc tout cet argent n'a pas été perdu
pour tout le monde
y compris aux États-Unis surtout en
Afghanistan et à Dubaï et d'autres et
cetera. Et c'est l'échec total de
calquer de l'occidentalisme de dire on
va apporter la démocratie participative,
les écoles pour les petites filles.
Voilà. Et encore les écoles pour les
petits filles, c'est très bien. Mais
faire de la formation au droits LGBT, à
l'armée afghane et cetera, bon ça a pas
formidablement marché quoi. Et donc la
situation est pire aujourd'hui parce que
effectivement
je veux dire la situation des femmes
c'est aucun droit surtout pas le droit
de se former et c'est une façon pour les
Pakistanais qui ne sont pas pour rien de
tout ça bah de maintenir l'Afghanistance
à un état de sous-développement dont il
ne pourra pas sortir.
Vous avez fait une BD ?
Ah bah oui.
Ça s'appelle comment ?
S'appelle Geostratégic. Alors, je l'ai
fait pas tout seul parce que
parce que voilà, j'ai fait surtout avec
Tommy. C'est un peu l'histoire des des
relations depuis 45 et l'état du monde.
Mais surtout, ça fait longtemps que je
voulais faire une BD.
Et Tommy c'est qui ?
Tommy, c'est son nom, c'est Tommy
Dessine et je suis tombé sur un jeune
dessinateur surtout par rapport à moi,
qui connaît la géopolitique et qui a
beaucoup d'humour. Alors en plus ce type
est très doué et là il a vraiment il a
vraiment complètement enrichi mes
textes. Il y a des fois les pages
entières et ça marche du tonner de feu
notamment dans les lycées et donc c'est
le cadeau idéal pour Noël évidemment.
Est-ce
que vous voulez pas le montrer un peu là
?
Ouais ouais voilà. Alors voilà il y a
bon vous voyez des des pages et puis
tout d'un coup comment je vais trouver
des pages pleines généralement.
Attendez il y a notre cadreuse préférée
qui va faire la mise au point. Tu es sûr
? magnifique.
Voilà, je vais retrouver ça.
Pourquoi c'est fait en en alors c'est
rouge, c'est ça ?
Ouais. Ouais, c'est en bicolore et puis
de temps en temps, enfin voyez des des
pages pleines et cetera. Mais surtout,
bon, je pense que personne n'a critiqué
le fond. On n pas dit tiens là, il y a
une connerie, là il y a une erreur ou
peut-être que personne l'a lu hein.
Ah bah si quand même. Si.
Combien de tirages ? Alors ça c'est le
l'intégrale parce que la le tome 1 et on
l'a vendu à près de 80000 exemplaires et
le tome 2 à 40 50000 et donc là c'est la
réunion actualisée des deux. Donc c'est
vraiment et bah ça marche du tonner de
feu parce que je crois qu'on a réussi
quelque chose et surtout en fait les
gens me disent bah on apprend on apprend
en s'amusant quoi.
Est-ce que vous pouvez mettre la
couverture sur votre cravate que ma ma
cadeau préférée puisse faire le cage
sans les doigts ?
Bon bon,
magnifique.
Bon,
question internet, il y a des choses à
rajouter sur la petite BD ?
Non non, c'est bon, ça suffit.
Ça coûte
euh 39 balles.
Ah, c'est pas donné quand même.
Oui, oui, mais il y a il y a 400 pages.
Ah bon, ça va
Vous l'avez envoyé à Stéphane séjourné
pour qu'il complète sa formation ou pas
?
Euh, écoutez, non, ça m'a échappé. Donc
voilà,
face à la Alors, question,
il est déjà colorié.
Il est déjà colorié. En plus, ces deux
couleurs, ça aurait été facile pour lui,
non ?
Vous vous prenez comment qu'on ait eu
Stéphane Séjourné au ministère des trêve
de plaisanterie Stéphane Séjourné
ministre des affaires étrangères.
C'était bien, c'était pas bien. Il
fallait que notre premier ministre
Gabriel Atal est un homme de confiance
au sein
président aussi. Notre président c'est
disons que ça a pas été vécu de façon
extraordinaire au quador c'est déconner.
Question internet. Face à la
concentration des capacités en
intelligence artificielle dans les mains
de quelques entreprises privées
américaines et chinoises, comment les
États peuvent-ils maintenir leur
influence dans les relations
internationales ? C'est un sujet majeur.
C'est un sujet majeur et qui m'angoisse.
Je je moi je suis pas scientifique, j'ai
rore des maths et cetera et pendant très
longtemps, j'ai voulu me tenir à l'écart
de ça parce que je bon et puis je me
suis forcé, j'ai écrit deux bouquins sur
l'IA, un essai, un bouquin pédagogique
parce que c'est un sujet majeur. Là vous
avez des individus privés. Moi, j'ai
j'ai toujours pensé que les États
étaient pas concurrencés dans l'aire des
relations internationales par d'autres.
Il restait au centre quand même du jeu
international. Avec Livec
Lia, ça change parce que vous avez des
types qui ont des fortunes plus
importantes que les PB des États.
Regardez le rôle d'Elon Musk par rapport
à la guerre en Ukraine. Ilony Sterlings.
Après, il dit faut pas les taper là.
C'est Bill Gates qui bon là de façon
positive paye la note de l'AMS que euh
que Trump ne voulait plus euh verser.
Euh c'est Elon Musk, c'est Jeff Bezos
qui veut conquérir Mars avec Elon Musk.
Et en plus
le grand danger, c'est que leur fortune
euh augmente tout le temps. Si c'est pas
régulé, les mecs vont aller vivre sur
Mars, ils vont dire "Débrouillez-vous".
Parce qu'en fait, pourquoi il y a une
sécu sociale ? Pourquoi on essaie
d'avoir les emplois ? parce que euh on a
besoin de mecs dans les usines, on a
besoin de mecs pour aller se battre,
faire la guerre. Si on a plus besoin
qu'on a des armes automatiques et des
robots, pourquoi se faire chier à
soigner les gens ? Euh et donc le je l'a
si elle est régulée, elle peut vous
permettre vous et moi, de vivre plus
longtemps en bonne santé, de tester
mieux, de détecter mieux les cancers, de
guérir et cetera, de développer la
production, le rêve de Marx, développer
les forces productives pour que ça soit
et cetera. Si vous pouvez produire plus
avec moins de temps, c'est très bien.
Mais si c'est pour augmenter les
inégalités et qu'il ait des masses de
gueux sans emploi pendant que d'autres
au coup de quelques gardiennages se
protègent d'eux et bah vivent des trucs,
à quoi ça sert d'avoir 1000 milliards de
dollars ? C'est quelle est la différence
entre les 500 premiers et les 500 et
cetera ? Donc en fait, on voit bien que
tous ces mecs
Bill B encore semblent avoir une
conscience sociale, mais tous les autres
c'est libertari.
Bon, il fait des dons au moins à l'OMS
et cetera les vaccins et tout. Bon,
enfin bref, mais tous les autres, tous
ces libri, il a une conscience.
Oui, honnêtement, je pense que sa
fondation a fait du du bon boulot, mais
les autres, c'est tout pour ma gueule.
De temps en temps, ils font un don pour
effectivement se dédouiner. De toute
façon, c'est disfisccialisé. Alors donc,
en plus, c'est pas très grave et cetera.
Mais je veux dire, on peut pas quand on
voit comment les salariés d'Amazon sont
traités, on peut pas dire que le bonheur
du peuple est l'objectif de Jess Bos.
Donc on a des vraies inquiétudes.
Heureusement au niveau de l'Union
européenne, Margarette Verstagen et
Thierry Breton avaient réussi un peu à
s'opposer aux gars femmes. Ils seront
plus dans la nouvelle commission.
J'espère là vraiment il y a un vrai
danger. Il y a un vrai danger. C'est un
sujet majeur, très angoissant. Question
internet, un commentaire sur
l'Azerbaïdjan.
Alors COP 29 c'est un pays dictatorial
qui a envahi une alors le haut Caraba ça
lui appartenait officiellement ils l'ont
récupéré mais enfin ils ont fait du
nettoyage ethnique à
un million de personnes sur les routes
voilà à grande il en reste un peu moins
mais enfin c'estage ethnique ils ont dû
partir et cetera de peur et cetera c'est
un crime. Mais oui oui c'est bon bon les
opposants sont mal menés
on a signé des contrats de gaz Ursula
Vleyen
oui oui parce que bah pour des raisons
morales on pouvait plus acheter aux
russes donc on était acheté là-bas
c'est les limites de la moraline.
C'est les limites de la moraline. Donc
effectivement et là ils font la COP 29
alors que ils vont augmenter leur
production de pétrole et avec ça bon et
on peut pas dire alors bon moi je sais
que l'argument on peut pas aller que
dans les pays démocratiques, faut bien
bon mais là quand même l'Arménie et tout
ça
on a été contacté par l'ambassade pour
faire un truc en commun avec eux on a
refusé.
Une petite dernière question internet.
Ouais, pour la route.
Pour la route.
Bonsoir. Quelles institutions
internationales et ou ONG ont grâce à
vos yeux
une direction pour un jeune ?
Bah en fait,
est-ce qu'il faut quitter la France ?
Non. Non, faut se battre en France pour
que ça change. Faut pas quitter la
France. Faut se battre en France pour
que ça change. Et l'ONU, le monde
n'irait l'ONU impuissante sur bien des
sujets, mais le monde n'irait pas mieux
si l'ONU n'existait pas. C'est quand
même intéressant de l'avoir. Ça ça
remplit pas tout l'objectif. Mais
pourquoi ? Parce que le problème c'est
pas l'ONU, c'est les divisions entre
grande puissance. Le NU n'est que le
réceptacle de cette division. Donc je
veux dire, s'il y avait pas l'ONU, le
monde irait moins bien. Il n'irait pas
mieux. Donc faut mieux garder l'ONU. Il
faut surtout pas quitter la France. Faut
qu' la France si tes rêves, c'est de
partir à l'étranger pour effectivement
il y a beaucoup plus d'expatriés
aujourd'hui parce que le monde est
globalisé et qu'il y a beaucoup plus
d'opportunités pour les jeunes et pour
les plus anciens de partir à l'étranger,
exercer un métier, faire des études et
cetera. Moi quand j'étais étudiant,
personne partait à l'étranger pour
étudier.
Oui, c'était en 1859
un peu un peu plus tard. Un peu plus
tard, c'était voilà et bon et maintenant
tout le monde le fait donc voilà. Mais
donc si tu vas à l'étranger, si tu as un
projet mais tu n'y vas pas pour fuir la
France.
Je me fais l'avocat du diable.
Ouais,
je peux
Bah oui oui.
Vous m'autorisez à être un petit peu
sec. Je sais que tu aimes pas ça
mais si si si on écoute je suis habitué.
Je suis habitué
avec la bande de crétins.
Ouais.
Qui dirige le pays depuis à peu près 25
ans avec la bande de tokar qu'on jamais
vu qu'on jamais rien anticipé.
La France elle est réduit en charpile.
Les perspectives économiques, c'est
zéro.
Le on est discrédité partout dans le
monde.
Alors ça bon
je fais exprès, je je grossil trait.
Ouais. Donc moi je reconnais que ça va
pas bien et cetera, mais raison de moins
de partir, je veux dire, il y a quand
même enfin on voit quand même vachement
de mobilisation des jeunes. Il y a
vachement de jeunes qui se mobilisent,
qui sont actifs, qui sont pas passifs,
qui sont dans plein d'assaut.
Généralement, ils s'engagent pas aux
politiques
parce que et disons qu'il y a il y a un
problème mais c'est marrant parce que
dans deux Finiew Émeric Caron et Pierre
Lelouche donc ils sont quand même pas
sur la même planète hein politiquement
les deux parlent d'une crise du
personnel politique et de l'engagement
politique et les deux disent bah en fait
on devrait et les deux d'ailleurs ont
fait carrière autre part avant de faire
la politique. Pierre était
universitaire,
euh essayiste et puis il est rentré en
politique. Emerck était journaliste et
il est rentré en politique. Là
effectivement si tu rentres en politique
pour devenir ministre ou pour devenir
député, c'est un peu différent. Donc bon
mais il y a plein bon voilà mais il y a
plein de jeunes qui s'engagent dans
plein d'associations qui font plein de
trucs. Moi franchement je suis ass quoi
de Jordan Bardella ?
Non qui il a travaillé cet hommel. Oui
oui. Bah non effectivement il a jamais
travaillé de sa vie effectivement bien
sûr. Oui c'est bon. Non moi en fait je
suis assez fier de mes étudiants. Je
vois mes étudiants, il ils font plein de
trucs vachement bien. Il c'est pas des
mecs tout pour ma gueule et cetera.
C'est pas je dire je me rappelle quand
j'étais jeune prof, c'était le complexe
du mec qui était the winner. Tu vois tu
avais the winner et the loser. La jeune
génération n'est pas comme ça. Il y en a
bien sûr mais majoritairement. Donc non,
faut surtout pas se barrer, faut se
battre, faut rester là, faut se battre,
faut pas se laisser faire, faut emmerder
les connards. Euh et il faut pas leur
laisser la place.
Il faut il faut euh des prédateurs euh
des carnivores, des omnivores. La petite
phrase de Macron là.
Ouais. qui était repiqué comas alors qui
a fâché tous les végétariens d'ailleurs
parce que effectivement bon c'est
végétariens, ils sont costauds quand ils
font du bodybuilding hein.
Oui. Oui. Mais donc là c'était vraiment
opposé. Non, je pense qu'il faut je dire
on parle de moins en moins de l'intérêt.
On parle de moins en moins de l'intérêt
national c'est devenu un mot tabou. Faut
pas avoir peur. Je me rappelle des bar
Hollande qui dit "Non, non, on est on a
on n pas venu au Mali pour l'intérêt
national." Du coup, tous les Maliens
pensent qu'il y a un truc qui est caché
et que si on le dit pas, c'est encore
pire. Il faut pas avoir honte de parler
d'intérêt national.
Et donc là, c'est pas carnivore et
herbivore. Et l'international, c'est pas
uniquement d'aller massacrer quelqu'un à
côté. L'international, c'est peut-être
donner une image positive du pays pour
que nos concitoyens soient appréciés
dans le monde entier et que ils puissent
en interne vivre une vie et cetera.
Donc, c'est défend l'international. On a
on a c'est devenu un gros mot
l'international comme réal politique,
c'est devenu un gros mot. Mais tous ceux
qui ont que la morale à la bouche et qui
débouchent sur des politiques
catastrophiques ou ceux qui ont la
morale à géométrie variable qui viennent
pas me parler de moral. Donc la réal
politique la réelle politique c'est pas
massacré la ré politique ne se résume
pas à massacrer les Cambodgiens et à
faire un coup d'état au Chilé en 73.
L'ar politique c'est voir analyser de
façon pertinente le monde pour savoir
comment on peut l'améliorer, comment on
peut le changer en mieux. Donc c'est
partir des réalités parce qu'il y a pire
que la politique, c'est l'iréal
politique, c'est partir de rêve, partir
de chimè, partir de oui, on va récupérer
la Crimée. Bah ça ça fait plus de mal à
la fin.
Comment il s'appelle votre bouquin là ?
Géostratégique l'intégral.
Géostratégique intégral. Est-ce que vous
avez trois livres à conseiller à notre
communauté ?
Oui. Alors, le labyrinthe des égarés
d'Ami Malouf, c'est formidable. C'est
c'est vraiment très très bien. C'est
c'est vraiment un bouquin. Vous avez des
bouquins,
vous dites tiens euh je suis plus
intelligent après l'avoir lu qu'avant
l'avoir lu. Nexus aussi de Harari
Valharari, c'est un peu moins bien
qu'odéus et sapience mais c'est quand
même bien. Et puis un bouquin qui est
moins connu, qui a pas été traduit mais
que je recommande
beaucoup, c'est
Bruno Leber. Non, c'est non, je l'ai.
Non, non.
C'est The H of Good Intentions de
Stephan Walls sur le sur l'hégémonisme
libéral et les erreurs que la politique
américaine a fait
d'en faire des bonnes intentions.
Et sinon, bon, il y a
puisqu'on parle beaucoup de Munique, euh
restons en français, le bouquin de
Gérard Aaro, nous étions seuls sur
justement les accords de Munique qui
montrent ce que c'était euh à l'époque
et qui t'en a parlé, autant savoir ce
que c'était. Est-ce que vous avez un
conseil pour les jeunes générations ?
Une bouteille à la mer
en fait. Continuez sur la voix que vous
prenez la plupart d'entre vous,
c'est-à-dire continuez à être actif,
informez-vous, ayez l'esprit critique,
vous laissez pas enfumer
par soyez critique et continuez à vous
informer et à être critique des
autorités, des profs et cetera. Voilà,
il y a faut challenger les institutions,
faut être intrusif, faut challenger les
institutions et bah essayer d'apporter
votre pierre, votre contribution à un
monde dans lequel vous allez vivre assez
longtemps
et sauver la France.
Bah pourquoi pas ? Pourquoi pas ? Ça
vaut le coup, ça vaut le coup de
travailler à restaurer ce pays.
Pascal Boniface, merci.
Merci à vous.
[Musique]